you
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record i'm marjorie
porter from the switzerland of new
england
um
and i i introduced this bill i bring
this bill forward because of a concern
that i have
that with all of the
new people that are coming into our
system to educate our children that the
children are safe
from predators and
other folks who should not be dealing
with them
my
my i filed the bill originally after
hearing about the prenda program which
is
quite possibly a wonderful program but
is designed so that um
there are pods of people working
together with a teacher that doesn't
have to be certified so the person that
is leading the group
does not need to go through
the department of education to get um
to get any kind of
requirements and that concerned me
because the idea i as i understood the
prenda program was that these small
groups of people uh children with one
adult in a in a spot that was would be
chosen by the
by the adult
is it was a potential for some
unpleasant experiences
so i brought this bill forward
it requires that anybody who is working
with children as part of a program that
accepts
public funds should be required to have
a background check as all teachers and
teachers aides and other folks in public
schools do
and with that i'll be glad to take any
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question how about
volunteers that may come in for a day or
two
thank you for that question and it is a
concern i know when i ran my my private
preschool in kindergarten there were
high school kids who came down
as part of their program outreach into
the community and they had to be
background checked
so volunteers in public schools have to
be background checked when they come in
and work with children it's it's to
protect the children especially in
situations where there's no direct
supervision over these folks so there's
not another adult in the room that is an
adult and a group of children or adult
and one child you just want to make sure
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um i'm just uh wondering
uh what is the intent in relation to
it's a new section
yep
it's to make sure that anybody who is a
volunt employee or a volunteer of any
entity contracted for educational
service by the department of
education who provides imperfect person
instruction
shall comply
with having a background check
so if the department of education or the
um
if a family
is
hiring a tutor
to tutor their child
that tutor
should have a background check because
that tutor is working with
a child without another adult
supervision
just as in the public schools they would
need to so the purpose is to make sure
any
person or school or
provider that's receiving our tax
dollars
should comply
as our public school
teachers do need to
a a tutor hired by a parent might not
necessarily be employed by the
department of education or certified by
the department of education so i'm just
wondering if there are any other
people who might meet the criteria
my understanding from what we heard the
other day
from the folks who administer the
scholarship fund
that they do require all providers
to go through a
rigid background check
if i understood what they were saying
you know it's a concern
of mine representative
that anybody who was hired to work with
a child
and is getting paid with tax dollars
that that person is a safe person to
have around children
and i'm not sure how i could make it
would this still hold if they were not
everybody that works with a child should
have a background check to make sure
that they are not
of a nature that might do harm to the
child so that was one i have a second
yes thank you a second question
which is
who authorizes and does the background
check who does the background check come
to the results who do the results come
to etc how does that actually work that
would have to be established by the
rules of the department i imagine if and
i believe they have rules already for
background checks for some people who
are being
who are working with the department of
education didn't the learn everywhere
program they talked about how all those
programs everybody that works with the
kids has to go through the background
check before they are approved for the
program so i'm hoping that
with all of these new programs we have
now we have prenda we have learn
everywhere we have efas where people can
take their children anywhere on
to to be educated that the people who
would working with the children are safe
people to have working with children
and the department would i'm sure have
to figure that out or the scholarship
granting organization or whoever else is
recommending or paying these people to
provide these services
okay further questions
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative porter for
bringing this uh forward so um would you
say that um that that this bill which
certainly um has a lot more uh to it
than the uh than the legislation that
formed the uh the so-called learn
everywhere program um that um
that that a process like what or a yeah
like a process like what the
department
does for uh for the quote learn
everywhere program
could um could number one help to
assure
that
that you've got um
qualifi or you know people that have
have cleared criminal background checks
and number two really put the department
in a position where they could be a
clearinghouse a huge support
for uh for parents that uh that may be
homeschooling their children and want to
see a list of
of tutors let's say that have um that
have cleared department uh criminal
background checks very much like the
learn everywhere program an enormous um
assistance to uh homeschooling families
and i yes i think it would be and you
know if i were a parent and i was hiring
someone to work with my child i'd want
to make sure that
person
wasn't someone who
has
a background of abusing children i mean
it just makes sense that i would know
that want to know that and simply saying
to the person
you don't have any background abusing
children is do you it's not a good
guarantee so i want to make sure that
any child that's getting services that
tax dollars are paying for that those
people that are providing those services
are
on the up and up we hear so many horror
stories i've heard horror stories in my
own town it's not a good situation when
someone who has a bad background
ends up with a group of children it's
just not good follow up on that yeah mr
i mean this is specific to um to um uh
family students who are receiving public
uh dollars to fund their their education
why can't they go and just do the
criminal background checks themselves
it's a rhetorical question
they could i said no no they can't
i don't think i don't know if they are
allowed to do that i mean they can't get
private records i don't know
certainly for the multi-state um right
right
further questions from the committee
representative thank you
thank you um i'm just looking at lines
uh 1516
uh section three
um
if uh someone um has a tax credit
scholarship for instance
um and is doing a home education program
are you saying that the parent needs to
have a background check
no
how about um
follow-up yes go ahead um uh i know a
lady in town who is doing a
history program for about uh 10 home
educated high school
uh students and i think maybe someone in
that group um has a tax credit
scholarship um would the woman
conducting that course be required to
get a
background check is she being paid with
those tax credit dollars
um i don't know if she's being paid or
not if she's being paid with tax credit
dollars if she's being paid with
taxpayer money then she needs to have a
background check if she's working with a
group of children alone in a room and
she has and she is receiving
public money she needs to be
safe for those children
yes
um
i i think and we can talk about this
more but
would you
would you agree that the courts
have
indicated that via tax credit
scholarship program or education savings
account anything like that where the
dollars are going to the family that is
no longer public money that is being
paid to the service provider are you
familiar with those
court rulings yes i am and i think that
that's the equivalent of money
laundering in my opinion
representative tanner
thank you
and
there's still court cases pending on
okay sorry
is that better
yeah okay
so uh
one of the things about this this bill
uh is that um you're asking for
background checks under rsa 77
g colon 8-a
which is something that we've been
talking about
representative mullen had some additions
to it about like trafficking human
trafficking and stuff
does this up the criminal background
checks that are currently
being done by um
this the scholarship organization in
other words some of these places that
say they're doing criminal background
checks are they really doing this 77-g
i don't know representative what the
scholarship organization is requiring
i don't know what
section of law they are going under
um
this specifically mentions 189 13 a
as well
as 77 g7 but this makes it clear that
you want them to have the
we we want them to have the same
criminal background check that a public
school teacher would have or a public
school
paraprofessional would have or anybody
in a public school system would have to
further questions representative nelson
thank you mr chairman and thank you i'm
sorry for another question
four and one incoming name four
organizations the 4-h
the teacher goes in to give a little
history class on the
state house tin mountain conference
conservation service and bringing a
guest speaker into a school would they
all need these checks if they're being
paid with top public dollars
according to this bill they would be if
they're volunteering most likely not
okay thank you
person like us you had a question
well i just had a follow-up because you
keep emphasizing if they're alone in the
room
and yet when i ask you said even if
they're not for instance if a parent
hires a music teacher
and sits in the lessons the whole time
that music teacher still needs i just
want to make sure i'm understanding
because the parents there
the whole time the teacher is there that
teacher would still need
a background check according to this
bill if the teacher was being paid with
public funds then the teacher would need
to have a background check okay thank
any further yes representative hobson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i just was looking
at the fiscal note on the back it
indicates that the cost is
indeterminable i was wondering if you
could speak to that
no they can't the
follow-up yes the department of
education can you tell me who would be
paying for these background checks would
it be the person applying or the doe
i would imagine that in order to get set
up to be a person who is
providing educational services under any
of these programs that they would take
it on themselves to pay for it
the people who are providing these
services
are not employees of the state but they
are receiving public money so therefore
it needs to meet i feel they need to be
sure
that they are safe to deal with children
i mean this is not a complicated issue
here this is a child safety issue we
don't want to find out five years from
now that there was some kind of an
organization that was using these kinds
of programs to get in and work with our
children i just think it's a protection
for them it's not a harmful thing it
shouldn't be in anybody's way to say you
can't provide the services it shouldn't
parents should be eager to do this
because they want to make sure that
their kids are safe and i just want to
make sure we have it in the law that yes
these things are required so parents can
be confident
thank you very much are there further
questions representative cornell thank
you thank you for taking my question if
i remember right a million years ago
when i became an educator i paid for my
own criminal background check
before they would hire me and i i think
that's still the way it is now well i
know when i had my certificate trans
extended to the state of new jersey in
representative woodcock
thank you representative um from the
live just a clarification if i may um
where i see that uh attorney fenton is
here
maybe give us some clarity on the
question of the scholarship has been
reported that the scholarship
organization provides criminal
background checks and it hasn't been
discerned if the background checks are
equal to or similar to or as similar as
our current background checks we do for
all the other sampling so perhaps you
could give us that information yeah i
plan on asking the department if they
have any technical advice for us on this
or we will get questions they have not
submitted a pink card
so at this point in time i'm going to
we've had her as a representative
senator and we've had her governor too
so you know
so i i mix and match and i'm sure she
appreciates perhaps that young woman in
the back pink cod could answer the
question later
thanks thank you
suggestion
that would be wonderful that's wonderful
okay so we're going to continue with
questions here for representative porter
if we have questions for representative
porter this time and then we'll get her
off the hot seat and get some others up
in front we do have one other card
that's come forward
representative can i just put forward a
concerning whether the money that's
going to education freedom accounts is
actually taxpayer money or not
when
citizens receive food stamp help
when citizens receive medicaid
when citizens receive other services
that are provided
by the government
is that not
taxpayer dollars going to those programs
even though they're going through
medicaid they're going through the food
stamp program they're still taxpayer
dollars and so that is why i believe
that this is important that it's my
money going to pay this person i want to
make sure my money is being used by
someone who is
worthy of working with children well
note that down as part of your testimony
i'm not going to respond to it
we're not going to take questions from
the people that are presenting
um so then uh we will ask that are there
any more questions for representative
porter
yes representative ford
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
my question has to do with service such
as i performed i had a former school
board member i volunteered as a to be
like a para assistant in the schools
just to see how things were working i
didn't know
and uh so i did i did that i had to have
a background check for it
that experience makes me wonder if
for that large number of people who
might and i say large because there are
a lot of them who do come in come into
schools to give presentations and talk
about what they do and whatever
i wonder if the key factor is and
they're not paid they just come in and
volunteer
so they might slip to this radar and yet
still be a threat to a child and so in
that i'm thinking
maybe that there ought to be some
provision uh for unescorted people or
some other definition added in addition
i know your concern is the dollars but
i'm i'm thinking of the intent of the
bill and just thinking in the same way
might it be a good idea to also put that
such people must be continually escorted
never left alone with with children
it's a possibility thank you for
bringing it up
further further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
and at this point in time um
we have represented are not represented
miss tunnel would uh here to present too
so before we get to our our kernel here
in the back of the room
uh then i'd like to have miss tuttle
come forward
welcome thank you chairman members of
the committee i'm not sure what to say
for the record i'm megan tuttle
president for any in new hampshire
representing 17 000 public school
educators across the state i do have
written testimony i'll pass in so i'm
not going to read the whole thing just
very simply we're here in support of
this bill you know the intent of it is
to have anybody that's working with
children
receiving public tax dollars to make
sure they have the same background
checks that educators in the schools do
i know that as a volunteer
on
pto for my
my third and fifth grader um just going
into the school to do anything for pto i
have to get background checked and
fingerprinted which i did
i'm somehow still on the middle school
pto even though i don't have children in
the middle school right now i'm not sure
how that worked um but i had to get
thing you know it's the same
fingerprinting process for all that so
you know we're here in support of that
if we look just this year and last year
legislature and the doe
have undergone several initiatives and
law changes to make sure that the
background checks were thorough and
we've added or you've added i shouldn't
say we we've been in support of adding
different um violations etc to this
um we have our educator code of conduct
which i always have my copy with me um
and so you know that's been passed
through and so i think just the intent
of this with everything that's been done
in the past few years it's it's it
should just happen i don't really know
um why we would hold
a private edu a private provider
to a different standard than we hold the
educators and the public schools to this
so
um i think this is a really good
opportunity to correct this and just
urge everyone to pass
thank you very much are there any
are you off the hook thank you very much
at this time we'd like to have the
individual from the department of
education
well you know you can be a full colonel
or a lieutenant colonel light colonel i
guess i'll just have to stick with a
lawyer that's great thank you as i
always tell people as a former
prosecutor believe me i've been called
worse so i will take
the names you've been giving me so i
want to provide a little bit of clarity
um when it comes to volunteers because
volunteers are always a conundrum
um
the law 189 13 a sets out that
volunteers are determined by policy
school district policy it is a local
issue and there are two groups of
volunteers there's volunteers and then
there's designated volunteers
each school district will have a
different policy that talks about what
is or who is um
a designated volunteer and the way that
i always explain it is if i were to go
to my son's school for the valentine's
day party most likely i would just be
viewed as a volunteer and therefore not
subject to the background check
but if i were to volunteer on a weekly
basis participate in you know teaching
the chess club or the ski club or
whatever school affiliated activity then
i would be a designated volunteer and i
would be subject to the background check
with all the work that this committee
and the house in general has been doing
on 189 13a
i will share with you that the majority
of school districts have had the
opportunity and the reason to go back
and revise those policies so i commend
you for that because i know that those
policies just hadn't been looked at
wasn't out of malice it was just out of
everyday life um but due to the work
this committee has been doing on this
important area a lot of those
school districts have had the
opportunity to revise that but generally
speaking that's the lay of the land when
i can also tell you in very general
terms
i
would think of myself as someone who's
pretty adamant about child safety given
my background and i think this committee
would agree but i i really pale in
comparison to the commissioner um i've i
honestly have never met anyone who is so
child
safety focused and so all of these
programs that the department is doing
i know that the commissioner and i have
spent many hours talking about how we
incorporate the background check into it
so with the learn everywhere program i
know in the rules and they are currently
revised and going through the jail car
process
there is a provision in there that i'm
happy to share with the committee that
talks about
that each entity has to have a policy
that follows 189
they are subject to those parameters
i will remind this committee that 189 13
a sets out those
as we call them those section 5
violations right that's kind of the
floor if you think of it i always
compare to the federal constitution
that's the floor of protection
each district can adopt a policy that
allows them to be more protective look
at other offenses that fall outside of
that section by violation
and so that's where you will see from
district to district from program to
program
discrepancies and differences that's
that local control piece that's at play
um you know in terms of this particular
bill again the department's not here to
support or oppose
i would suggest that we be consistent
with our statutory numbers where we look
at on page 1 line 17
did checks under rsa 77 g8a
if the intent
is to be in compliance with 189 13 a
i think that has to
be throughout um
there was a question about
the um
the fiscal note i completed the fiscal
note on behalf of the department um the
cost was indeterminable because looking
at the language especially at the top of
the bill lines three through six
um
looking at it as an attorney i felt that
it was overly broad
um and so
it is impossible to calculate what this
encompasses
when you look at any employee or
volunteer of an entity contracted for
educational services
that is very fluid that concept is very
broad and so it's hard to quantify that
and so that's why we have the
indeterminable
number
thank you
thank you are there questions for
attorney fenton president
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you very much attorney fenton for uh for
joining us this morning um
you had mentioned um just now that um
that the the new rules i guess pending
before jlcarr
with respect to the learn everywhere
program
require the
learn everywhere
providers
to follow the procedures outlined in 189
colon 13a
and
and the one of the procedures that
really jumps out at me
is um is found in
13 a
roman 2
where where an applicant
for employment
with the school
in fact it says with a school
administrative unit school district
charter public school or public academy
so it doesn't specifically call out
learn everywhere programs or education
service providers or whatever terms the
department wants to use for
tutors service providers things like
that but it's certainly pretty broad you
know historically captures
you know up until learn everywhere and
and voucher program sort of captures the
uh the network of education providers in
the state but anyway that a prospective
employee
submit a
an authorization um
or submit a release that authorizes the
state police to conduct a criminal
history records check
through its state records and through
the federal bureau of investigation and
to release
the report those reports to the
superintendent or designee of the school
administrative union or the chief
executive officer of the charter public
school of public academy i was wondering
if you could say how that works
for
service providers in the learn
everywhere program and uh and in the
voucher program as to the mechanics of
it yeah um
so i will have to get back to you and
i'm happy to do that that's more of a
department of safety
issue the department does not department
of education does not house and maintain
those records and so who the records are
being released to to review and make
that determination excellent question i
will
link back with our partners at the
department of safety and get you that
answer okay and a quick quick follow-up
on this and this may be uh uh
get back to us on on it as well but um
if uh if i'm a parent of a um of a of a
student who of an efa student
and um uh and i'm interested in in
hiring a tutor
can i request the state police to
conduct a criminal history records check
and um
as well as the fbi uh multi i think
that's a multiple state
records check and have that information
released back directly back to me as the
so
again i'm going to do the let me talk to
the department of safety and get back to
you the department of safety is
regulated by very strict fbi regs um i
have a cursory understanding of them but
i don't want to misspeak so let me talk
to them and i can get back to you on
that
and one final follow-up along this
technical line of of questioning
however the department
does um complete
criminal history records checks for
let's say school bus drivers
and uh and that information is
is released to the department
is that correct yes so the department
has the ability to do this
yes so when you look at 189 13 b which
pertains to the bus drivers and we've
talked about that previously in 189 13c
which pertains to first-time teacher
applicants those are newer initiatives
that the department is undertaking um
so yes the department is a governmental
entity and we can work with our partners
as a department of safety and receive
those background checks and process that
um so as we have discussed previously in
my prior testimony that is a role that
the department is taking on
that infrastructure is fairly new we are
currently building it um but yes that is
something that we are we're facilitating
great great so the so the outstanding
question then is
how do learn everywhere providers do it
and how would a parent of an evas efa
student
do it yes and i can get you those
answers i just want to double check with
the department of safety because they
get really crabby when i speak on their
behalf and i don't work for them and and
they're pretty well armed
thank you very much diana thank you
further questions representative tanner
thank you um
i have actually two questions one is
that i know words really matter uh you
know as coming from a teacher into this
legal atmosphere
even the may shell you know business so
i'm wondering what the word follows
uh is
used in in legalese
when you said that they follow does that
mean they have to they shall they are
required
uh they may what does that mean
thank you for the question i'm just
going to pull up the learn everywhere
because i think when um
so the the language that i used was
simply that it was my language if you
look at the language in the
learn everywhere program rules it is a
mandate that
the program providers have to follow
the law as laid out in 189 13a so what's
applicable to
educators in the public school system is
equally applicable
to the service providers so that's
that's the language looking at it i
don't see that word following that was
just a word that i
that i used okay didn't have the
significance i thought it was that's
okay that's okay my other question is
about the scholarship organization
do they use the same
the same set of criminal background
checks that the educational systems the
educators have to use in public schools
and do they
check all all the employees of the
of the organization as well as the
people that they're
they're vetting to release the public
funds to through the efa
i i believe that they do i
don't want him to speak so i'm going to
do the i will get back to you on that
exact answer because again i just don't
want to
to mislead but i believe that when we
look at these issues as a department
and recognizing the importance of child
safety and that's never been in doubt at
the department we always refer back to
1889 13 a that is our guiding principle
and 189 13 b and c were all premised
upon that
so we use that as our structure and we
don't deviate from that
um and so i i know when speaking with
the commissioner it's been very clear as
a policy of the department
that's the application and the
application is consistent across the
board the
the implementation
right again we're going to defer to
these entities to have that policy that
is consistent with pursuant to whatever
word you want to
utilize
that law that is the law that we always
go back to that is the criminal history
background check law so i think that
piece of it
will always be consistent throughout
those programs okay just uh follow up
well let's you said two questions oh
well this is kind of a follow-up
question
okay
so
um one of the issues i i remember
dealing with in the past
was that for example uh learn everywhere
might
have a
contract with a small business that has
employees that that person is working
the student is working with and as a
person that's an employee of this third
party
they
do routine criminal background checks
and credit checks on these people to
employ them
but their criminal background checks are
you know for like stealing and things
that they don't they don't flag
in particular like trafficking and child
sex abuse and you know some of the
things that we have it might not be
child safety focused right okay not
child safety focus
um
and so when you say they're following
our guidelines are you saying that
they're
doing criminal background checks but
we're really not making sure that
they're using the criminal background
checks that have child safety
uh specific child safety um
issues involved in it
well again speaking of very general
terms
when the department looks at these
programs and implementing them i can
tell you that this has been a very
robust discussion at the department and
these programs are not administered or
implemented or started without this
being a consideration
i can't even begin to count the number
of hours that the commissioner i have
spent talking about child safety and
again
we always go back to 189 13 a we
recognize that individual
private entities
might not have those child safety
focused
policies
and so that is why you see language such
as you need to have a policy that is in
accordance with
that
that criminal record law
that guides all of our actions when we
look at
child safety and working with children
so how that's implemented on each
individual program
i want to get back to you on that
because it's very detail-oriented but in
in a broad policy sense
there is not a certain program that goes
by the department that doesn't reference
that that law
thank you
thank you very much uh represented
litchfield did you have a question
i did thank you i think you might have
answered it just now though um so
i think i'm looking for a teachable
moment for me selfishly um
having sat or i sit currently on a
couple of school boards in a very large
district and we've gone through these
policies that you are we're discussing
right now as far as child safety is
concerned and we've gone round and round
many times about to what extent do we do
a background check on the volunteers
does it make sense
is it cost effective and would it really
make it safer for the children so my
question is
i know rep porter has just mentioned
that she's heard some horror stories in
her district
i know that there are probably
a variety of background checks but my
question is if we were to actually do
these background checks how much
information
do we actually
capture is it only if someone has
actually been convicted
i'm just curious how effective it is to
do these background checks and if it is
done through the doe does that impact
the liability for the doe and i'm gonna
take it even a step further i feel like
safety is absolutely important i have
four children myself that being said i
witness even at church people are afraid
to help a child in the restroom because
what you know i could be held liable for
this so i'm kind of doing a little dump
here and hoping you can help me out
uh i
i think in my past job we'd call that a
compound question
um but uh well done
you did it very well um
all right so
a couple of things
when you look at the law
and you look at the section 5 violations
which are set out it says if a person is
has been convicted
or is currently pending disposition for
and that's just a fancy word for
awaiting trial
um and so it captures the conviction and
it captures the pre-trial
piece of it historically i can tell you
when i started with the department in
2015 what was being released by the
department of safety to the individual
school districts because the department
of ed was not playing a role in this
issue at that time
was simply a letter
and the letter simply said the person
has a
section five conviction or they don't
and i can tell you when i first saw this
letter i i said what what is this
because i had come from a very different
world a very different background where
as a criminal prosecutor you got
someone's entire criminal history and so
it was very shocking to me
and school districts were relying on
this letter and not really realizing
that there's a lot of information
potentially in someone's criminal
history and what i mean by that is there
are a lot of different dispositions
you can be arrested for something and
have it be placed on file or pending or
in massachusetts they do a conviction
without a finding and i still don't know
what that is um but there's all these
different variations on a theme if you
will
and what happened sadly is that we had a
case
out in the western part of the state
where an individual was charged with
really severe
sex offenses against a child and for
whatever reason those charges were
reduced down put out
and i can't speak to the reason behind
it
and when that person applied for a job
in a school
they were subject to the criminal
background check just like everyone else
pursuant to that law
and the department of safety pursuant to
the law at the time released a letter
that said the person did not have any
section 5 violations because they didn't
the offenses had been pled down
and that victim was brave enough so he
was employed in the school and
reoffended
that victim was brave enough to come
before this committee this house and
testify to her experience and it was
this legislative body that changed the
law to allow for the release of
all offenses
and now you'll see misdemeanors and
felonies which is why section 5 says
that each school district can create a
policy
which allows them to take into
consideration offenses that fall outside
the section five violations
last legislative sect um session or it
might have been the one before i got to
be honest with you the two kind of blend
together do the pandemic so i don't know
which year it was but most recently
the law was amended again to allow for
the complete release which goes beyond
just convictions so you will see things
that were null process which means the
state dismissed the charges and so
school districts um
are now receiving the entire record
uh
people can debate
i will always say and i've said it
before when you're dealing with children
it's good to have all the information so
you can make a well-informed choice we
are not hiring people to put widgets in
a box we're hiring people to put be
around children so the more information
the better and i will give significant
credit to representative mullen who
passed a law that requires the
department of ed to do trainings for
districts on criminal histories and we
have been doing that throughout the
state on a routine basis and every time
i do one i call representative mullen
and say law in action i just did your
training uh so we've we
have been out doing those with the
department of safety and we've been
getting a lot of requests on that to
provide that information so it's again a
nice partnership with the department and
the districts to say
we live in a new world now right we
can't rely on a letter that says no
section 5 violation or yes there is no
there isn't we have to have this
information we recognize how critically
important it is and the department
recognizes how critically important it
is and we put that emphasis into all
these various programs that we're doing
in these initiatives that are going
forward
you asked about liability
there's criminal liability and there's
civil liability
and there's a significant difference
between the two i'm not really here to
opine on it
um
but
is it a possibility of a lawsuit
yes lawsuits are possible um
i i don't know how much deeper i can go
on that um and i don't mean to be
flipper or
disrespectful but it is a pretty broad
topic and perhaps
worthy of a conversation offline um but
i appreciate the opportunity for the
question
thank you thank you very much uh are
there
further questions i want to you know
sort of like slow down these questions a
little overlapping the other this is
technical support we can get that for
the committee even after this particular
hearing
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
attorney fenton uh you referenced in a
in conversation this morning that you
and the commissioner always talk about
student safety whenever new programs are
coming online
has a conversation taken place between
you and the commissioner regarding
educational service providers in the efa
program
and if so
are there going to be rules written or
uh what what would
what's the department recommending in
terms of the process for checking out
the backgrounds of the esps
sure and i'm going to put the details of
that into the same bucket i did with
representative luno
i can get back to you with those details
but
the short answer is yes in every
initiative we undertake we always have
that conversation and that is always
paramount um
and
what it looks like in every program
might vary a little bit but it's always
going to come back to that same law that
we've been discussing that is our
gutting principle
and it's just a question of how we apply
it
thank you
good
and
do we need to put something into law do
we need to codify
189 a as part of the efa program
to be sure
that people that are employed as as
vendors or providers or contractors
whatever we want to call them
i think
whether or not it's codified in the
statute is really beyond my pay grade
regardless of what title this committee
continues to give me at various times
um
but that's what the rulemaking is for
and that's what we've seen in the learn
everywhere program so there's there's
there are avenues by which the
department can and does successfully
implement
the reference to the statute
whether or not this committee wants to
codify it in in the statute
is
within your purview to do so but just
because it's not
codified in the statute doesn't mean
it's not implemented it can be
implemented in other ways via the
rulemaking process and we've seen that
throughout
and we've seen that in relation to
another bill which we've been dealing
with this year is do we put something in
statute or do we work through rule
and that's that's a good question it has
a lot of uh detail we have to look at
because at times it's wiser to work
through rule rule can be changed quicker
than statute can be
and and so there's a lot more to it and
we discussed that in terms of one other
area which we involved several folks on
earlier not more than a week and a half
two weeks ago
representatives yes i have two questions
one is i remember when we tried to do
this before
and and
as you've said a lot of things have
changed
since then and i'm wondering did
anything ever change or happen
at the department concerning um
like tutors who might teach lots of
different places is there does the
department now have
a way for them to
you know like a list or whatever a way
for them to do one
background check that the department has
or would we still have to do
a background check every time we have a
new student
so currently that particular scenario
would be dealt with as an employment
matter that would not be something that
falls within the jurisdiction of the
department of education our authority is
enumerated quite clearly in 189 13 b and
13c
and it does not at this time
involve tutors
okay
and and the other one is just from a
legal perspective
i don't really understand
uh
section one
and who exactly i mean volun any
employee or volunteer of an entity
contracted for educational services by
the department it's like
well i will reference the previous
testimony i gave as it pertained to the
fiscal note um
in
in answering the fiscal note and writing
the fiscal note i i grappled with the
the piece that this language that you
refer to and i will refer to as well
lines three through six
i found to be overly broad and i wasn't
sure who it
i wasn't sure how to quantify it and how
to address it
um and that's why we put down that it
was indeterminable because i felt that
this could be in it could be read a
variety of ways and it was very um
very large that pool was was very large
potentially
depending on your interpretation thank
you
thank you thank you very much
representative woodcock yes
well i think thank you training i just
want to thank you for coming forward and
answering my questions
you're very welcome
so
i'm not as familiar with this as other
members of the committee giving my
temporary status but what i think i'm
hearing you say is at least part of this
bill codify stuff that's already in the
rules am i hearing that correctly
yes
i would have to look at the efa rules
and then we can puzzle it out from there
okay that's fair and i'm happy to get
back to you on that but
again
all the
the programs that we do
we incorporate the reference the
criminal history reference check um so
yes we can we can pull those sections of
the rule and line them up and see which
ones are are redundant or already
incorporated but yes the short answer to
your question is it's incorporated
already
follow-up yes but even if they're
already in rules there is a reason to
codify this
as well i mean there's a reason we
codify things beyond what's in the rules
so just because they're in the rules
doesn't mean this shouldn't be passed
necessarily
wouldn't you agree that there could be
additional implications if we codify
this
two lawyers battle it out in the ring if
i didn't know you were a lawyer before i
don't know
i'll withdraw the question
i think that um
you know this this legislative body
will have its reasons to to codify it in
the statute whether or not i agree with
that is irrelevant
but yes it would have certain
implications if you were to codify in
the law thank you
that discussion can go on forever
and i'm married to a lawyer so it's just
must be fun at breakfast and lunch and
dinner
so am i and believe me
the first grade teachers also okay i
think what we're going to do this this
bill right here is not an early bill
we have to have it out of this committee
by on march by march 10th
so there's a little bit of time to
there's been a lot of questions asked
here
and it might be wise for us to just
consider a committee the whole
subcommittee work session
somewhere along the way here and give
some time for the department to come
back with some of the responses to what
we've asked and then we can have further
discussion at that particular moment
so rather than
having more questions to you right now
attorney fenton colonel fenton governor
fenton
i would also suggest that we involve our
partners at the department of safety
because they have been really critical
in this i think it'd be wise thank you
thank you we'll try and set something
like that up and working with you
so with that we have no more pink cards
on this particular bill so we're going
to close this hearing
and we'll move into the next bill which
is on the docket that is
1402 in relation to inclusion of charter
public schools and school district bond
and so with that i'd like to welcome
representative mooney who is the prime
thank you
good morning mr chairman
mr vice chairman
members of the committee
for the record my name is maureen mooney
state representative from the town of
merrimack hillsborough county district
number
21. i'm the prime sponsor of house bill
and in support of it the title is an act
relative to inclusion of chartered
public schools in school district bond
issuances
i have for convenience
given my testimony in written form to
the clerk who i believe has distributed
to all of you
in an attempt to very carefully go
through the bill to give you
an
overview the intention of the bill is to
allow chartered schools
participation in the bond process
as well as open the lines of
communication further between school
districts
and public chartered schools
this can be done
within this bill
as follows
placed in the municipal finance act
which is found in rsa 33 colon 1 through
33 colon
20.
number one
and this is again the process
taking you through the process
in this bill of how this would work
school districts
considering
submitting questions of authorizing
bonded indebtedness
shall invite
chartered public schools
to participate in discussions
and are encouraged keyword there
to voluntarily include
funding for capital construction needs
of chartered public schools
in the district's question
of authorizing bonded indebtedness
this is
side note away from my script here this
is probably the most important point of
the bill is that the school district
offer the invitation
to the public chartered school in their
town or city
to be part of the discussion
if a bond question will go on
the ballot
key
point there to open lines of
communication
number two
if the chartered public school has
construction needs
it may request that the local school
board include it as part of a ballot
question
for approval of bonded indebtedness for
the voters
and the chartered public school
in that conversation with the school
district that has construction needs
must
submit a detailed capital construction
plan
to the school district board that
includes specified items
those specified items are in sections
one through eight
in the bill
section roman two
the school board now
shall notify the chartered public school
in writing
whether it has accepted or not
the capital construction needs for
inclusion in the ballot question
this gives the school board the
authority to accept or reject
then i break it down into two scenarios
my items four and five in the written
testimony
scenario one
if the school district accepts
the chartered schools
needs
the chartered public school capital
construction needs shall be included in
the same ballot questions submitted by
in scenario 2
if not accepted the school board says no
to the chartered public school
construction needs
then the chartered public school has an
opportunity
to address any issues provided in
writing
by the school board
additionally
the bill allows for alternative
financial plans
whereby school districts and chartered
public schools may
agree
to an alternative financial plan
addressing facility needs
for benefit of chartered public schools
such plans could include and this is
text taken from the bill
retiring financial obligations
previously issued for the benefit of the
chartered public school
the final section of the bill
so that is section
amends the chartered public school
reference
to the process of bond issue
this is the same section stating that
the state is not liable for any debt or
other obligation
now for my concluding remarks
the bill
strengthens communication
between school districts
and chartered public schools
again i bring you back to number one in
my testimony here the conversation
begins
the school district
and the chartered public school within
the district are in conversation about
building and construction
needs
chartered public schools are public
schools
they have needs just like
traditional public schools for lack of a
phrase
that includes construction costs this
bill would bring them into the
discussion
this bill also provides options for
funding capital construction costs for
chartered schools
being part of a bond
process if the school board
determines
it's good
and
lastly this bill will clarify whether or
not chartered public schools are even
allowed to process to participate
in the bond process
because that is unclear in current law
and with that
i want to thank you for your attention
i want to thank you for your service to
our state
i believe this will be the last bill
i'll introduce in this committee this
year
uh and i want to thank you again mr
chairman you're welcome
are there questions from the committee
so if i representative mooney if i'm
understanding this you're asking
a local school district to take on
responsibility for a bond for a school
over which it has no authority am i
correct
thank you for the question i would say
not necessarily no
because in the discussions would be
uh and if the school board were to
accept the plan
there would be further discussion as to
how the question will be phrased how it
will appear in the voter guide who the
bondholder will be and the like
so
in
some to answer your question
no not necessarily follow-up yes
but i don't understand how
that financing information has any
relationship to whether the school board
or the school district has any control
over that charter school that charter
school is an independent institution so
you're asking a community to take on the
financial responsibility for an
independent institution which is going
to be independent in the way it's run
who it hires what the principal is what
their policies are independent of the
school district and the school board yet
the the town would despite the fact they
don't have control over the way the
school is run would then be financially
responsible
that's my
understanding of this help me if i'm
wrong
thank you for that and i can't see
where every conversation every
discussion that the chartered public
school is invited to from the public
school board would result in the
scenario you painted so i believe that
they would continue the chartered school
would be able to continue its autonomy
but there would be discussions extensive
discussions on how this would work but
at least the door here is opened i don't
see um that scenario you painted
coming to light
in every conversation between the
are there for the questions
and luna
so thank you very much and
and i i think you know representative
mooney
that that we need to be completely
transparent with um with
the citizens of new hampshire when it
comes to bills like this
and that we can't
sort of
say well not necessarily or really i'm
not really sure if it would go that way
i think we need to be completely clear
so
i'd like you to explain
how
the word shall on line 11 doesn't
actually commit the voters
in a school district
to
to assuming
the financial costs associated with a
bond for a private
um
institution
thank you for that question
so that shall appears in my number one
in my
testimony
shall invite
it does not say
shall commit to the debt of the charter
school shall have their question be
included in the school district's
question in the upcoming election it
doesn't say that it says shall invite to
participate in discussions
then
you go through the rest of the sections
here by trying to summarize it and
describe it would be then the process of
what happens keeping the school board
basically in control
after those discussions if the school
board says no to the construction plan
you can't be on our ballot question the
and i agree with your point about
transparency absolutely
but i also agree that chartered public
schools like other public schools have
the same needs
and that includes
costs
of and updates and so on related to
facilities
so i guess in some
i don't see where shell
takes on anything other than continuing
with the rest of the sentence
participate in discussions regarding the
possible
another emphasis
submission of such a question
there is no commitment
in section roman
a
other than
hey we're having a discussion on a bond
representative woodcock
thank you chairman uh thank you
representing to take my question i enjoy
watching you perform um the my question
specifically deals with uh the building
piece and usually representative ladder
luna have
not usually always have much better
understanding of that than i
but in this case if i was a chartered
public school
and i received students from
hitherto
to the enrollment
how would
the
other sending hitherto schools be
responsible or pay their share
of this uh building process because
am i thinking i may be incorrect um but
i thought typically they'd be the
bonding for that town or school district
so how do the other participating uh
districts pay their share of their
bonding under this scenario
yeah it's a good question and the answer
is um they don't
it is on the the uh the town or the city
where the school district is located
so unless uh future legislation would
have a you know money follows the child
sort of scenario the answer to your
question is uh they don't as far as i
thank you so
so i'm privately clearing this i'm
coming
my town is going to pay with no chance
for reimbursement under this bill
for students from other sending towns
they're paying no cost for that unlike a
cooperative school or a regional school
they're just coming in and they're free
basically
to the top
yes however
in your question you mentioned um and
thank you for the follow-up you
mentioned um
a scenario that taking on the
indebtedness that doesn't necessarily
based on the discussions that could be
had
between the charter school and this in
the school district you know they might
be able to figure something out beyond
um
you know say you're a charter school in
manchester and you're dealing with
manchester school board manchester
united take on all of our construction
and thank you for being here
so my question has to do with if you can
cast your mind back to last year 2021
we passed hb 278 i think it was
and that passed this committee passed
the house passed senate governor signed
it into law and that was the bill that
gave charters uh first dibs if that's
the right way to put it on unused or un
or available
vacant whatever public school properties
so my question
is that
if that bill which is now
codified
already a special relationship between
districts and charters
is does that bill have a relationship to
what
you're trying to move forward here thank
you for the question i do recall the
bill i gave the parliamentary inquiry on
the bill and it won by five votes
through the house it is certainly
a help
it is certainly a plus
but this bill would open that door even
wider
in fact in consultation with those who
will testify after me that bill has come
up several times and it's in agreement
that everyone is is very much
in favor of that bill and looking
forward to it and it does open lines but
this would open lines further in terms
of
construction costs
and
building needs
thank you representative
ford
thank you mr chair uh and thank you
representative for taking my question
sorry i put myself in there
way down the list behind representatives
lad luno and woodcock in terms of
understanding of how this is this works
but uh a question i have will be on page
three
uh lines 15 through 21
which deal with
a charter school public charter school
becoming insolvent and then it talks
about that the charter school shall
repay to
to the district at a rate of five
percent if a school is insolvent and in
fact
doesn't have resources how are they
going to repay the bond to the school
district if they don't have the
you know that's a good question and i'm
glad you brought up that section because
i didn't mention it in my testimony
but it's an important section and that's
the the wrap up if in fact there's a
school that is in the situation you
described
i would refer you to line 14
where it mentions that if in fact the
chartered school goes forward
with a bond question and the like they
will enter into a contract
with the school district where the
charter school is located
that would spell out
exactly scenarios and terms as you
described as for the specifics of that i
cannot get into that i don't know the
answer but i would imagine that in that
section entering into a contract like
that
various chartered schools various school
boards a scenario like that would be
included
and accounted for
follow-up
yes
uh
given that scenario then i would assume
there would be in that agreement
there would be some answer to the
question that i asked which is
the charter entire school's insolvent
does not have resources and therefore
we're not going to repay the school and
everybody's going to agree to that i
would
is that your question yes i agree with
that
thank you yes i do i think exactly what
that contract will do representative
ford
thank you mr chair
and thank you for entertaining my
question
i asked a question in a similar
discussion some time ago about who owns
the property
i think i should have rephrased it at
that time and i'm asking you
wouldn't this be clarified if this
stated that
whoever provides the funding shall hold
a lien on the property
from the get-go
and so you don't pay it back we own the
property
and that's the person who paid out the
money and that in this case it would be
the school board or the town or whatever
but that
wouldn't that simplify this process
thank you for the question i remember
the question from last week i would
agree with that yes i think that would
be a friendly amendment
and um
in addition any sort of um clarification
as to ownership and the like which what
you're proposing would do
there are a lot of questions on this
i understand and i would you know to
remind the committee that there are
those speaking after me um
and perhaps if there are questions
that they can't answer or
better directed to me i'd be happy to
come at the end again
but
i understand the specifics of this and i
would ask that others behind me also
have things to contribute your question
to the person testifying right now
represent
yes you're talking about if school
boards
have a bond
are already thinking of a bond issue and
my question is can the charter school
come
if the school
board doesn't have a bond issue on their
regular
you know where they're doing contracts
and all of that
can the charter school still ask
if there can be a bond put on
thank you for that and that's very
important and that was related to my
concluding remarks it's unclear
i would say the law is unclear on that
very point
i don't know the scenario playing out if
a chartered school were to approach the
school board and ask how the school
board would receive that
but this bill would hopefully
um clarify that or an amendment that
would even say that would be very
beneficial because right now
it is unclear and that's the best i can
answer that question thank you for that
okay thank you very much for your
presentation we'll go on to the next
speaker right now
i'm bill phillips um with the national
alliance for public charter schools uh
thank you once again for having me
um
you know i was actually doing just fine
with the way you were going there pepper
and her with those questions i was
writing them down frantically but uh
and i can answer there's a couple there
that i'll actually i can help answer but
um from a testimony standpoint
let me um
you have you have my testimony so let me
just speak broadly to a little bit of it
the rationale for the bill is twofold
and i talked a little bit about this
last week
in that
you have a situation in new hampshire
now
where your charter schools for the most
part are using their they're using
uh funds that should go for programming
for their facilities
and i actually for what it's worth um
in the two pages the back page i gave
you
forgive the presentation on it but on
the right side of it there was a survey
done in 2018
that surveyed the charter schools and it
identified a number of ways of which
they were they were having programming
issues
due to funding issues
so my point is that
once they're up and growing
uh there there's a need for help with
their facilities so that they can
actually implement their programming and
not have to use their operating funds
for
uh for facilities
you know the programming funds for
facilities if you will
the other reason for this which was
which was not stated but which we have
seen in a couple other states
i don't think i have to tell you that
school bonds are hard to pass
um
including the charter interests in the
bonding process i think actually may
make it easier to pass the bond at some
point
um
i mean that's actually what you what
you'll see in other places i mean look i
live in a place where i don't remember a
bond ever passing by more than three
four five five percent and
you're going to get to some places where
you're you know the charter community is
going to be three four five percent i
think you might want them
energized and involved in your bonding
process and so this actually
one of the things that um representative
mooney mentioned
we actually
checked a missile fight the municipal
finance act it is not it is not clear on
this
um it is not clear that the charters and
the districts can work together on
bonding it is not at all clear that they
can
do their own their own bonding
um if i may answer your question the way
the law is currently written
i i don't think the charter could
so the law right now is not clear at all
if we pass this bill i don't think it's
clear that the charter could do it on
its own as well and honestly i'm not
sure how they would actually pass a
pass a bond you know it's they're still
a pretty small part of the population
i'm not i wouldn't be against that
amendment but
i think the reason this would work is
when you start to get the district
interest in the charter interest on the
same page
so
um
okay so i want to in very
broad terms explain what we're trying to
do here
the district's considering bonding
they're obligated to to
notify the charter of its intentions
the charter has the right to request
participation in the bonding effort
the district has the right to say no
okay very very clear this is voluntary
i will answer there were a number of
questions that were asked that were
related to why would this make sense i
think you shouldn't lose sight of the
fact that remember the taxpayers
actually get to say no
so so for instance if um
representative ellison you asked a bunch
of questions as to like why would they
do this if they don't give a good answer
you know what they're going to lose the
bond fight don't forget the taxpayer
gets to say no even if the district says
yes
um
last point here and then i'm actually
just if you'll let me i'll run through
some of the questions that were asked
earlier
i want to flag for you um
in the past month
representative mooney we and i we've
we've presented three different kind
three different kinds of facilities
bills we did a revolving fund we did
building aid last week and then we've
got this bonding bill
here
context behind that is
you have a state i realize this is not
100 of the state feeling that way but
you have a state now that is interested
in growing the charter
space
the things that get in the way of that
are lack of startup funds facilities
problems and access to talent
you dealt with a startup issue when you
accepted the federal csp grant which i
realized was a little bit dramatic for a
while but you dealt with it
um
this is about dealing with the the
the other piece if you looked at that
second page
i had flagged for you that there's a
fairly decent sized gap between
district and charter funding
let me tell you what i'm not saying with
that is i'm not saying oh you got to
even that up or you don't care about
kids i am not saying that i don't know
what the right number is frankly
what i'm actually telling you
is when i look at a lot of states and
when i see
that kind of a gap it doesn't surprise
me that the charters are just having a
hard time
getting their buildings paid for so what
we're trying to do is just give you some
solutions to actually help fix that
problem
the lease aid work you did last year the
the uh the disposition the local the 278
representative bill you were talking
about for that
those are all great steps they all help
solve the problem this just helps it a
bit more and that's the context that i
would hope you'd consider this with
um mr chairman do you before i take
questions do you mind if i answer a
couple of the questions that were asked
or i'll i can do either way well um we
are on a tight rope here uh we did get
some responses from the representative
who presented the bill
uh if you can go over that in a minute
or two that'd be fine but i don't want
to get into a lengthy discussion on that
at this point in time yep okay um how
about this there was one piece that i
that i would want to clarify
um
there was uh representative ford you
asked the question about who owns the
building
you could do it by an amendment or the
other thing you could do
charters
typically enter into what are known as
dissolution agreements with the state
so you could actually write that into
the disillusion dissolution statement
where
the way it could be
the town owns the building or it could
be
in the case of dissolution the charter
is obligated to sell the building
and pay off the bond holders and the
taxpayers you you can do it either way
the dissolution agreement just might
give you
maybe what you want to make sure you
have an amendment on is making sure
there is a dissolution agreement that
way would be the most flexible way that
they could actually write it to
fit local circumstances
thank you
are there are there questions from the
committee
nassim thank you very much
pleasure thank you again for having me
good morning mr chairman and committee
members my name is kim lavalley i reside
in mount vernon and i'm here in support
of hb 1402
i recognize your time is tight so i'll
just
go over some of the highlights i think
clearing up the law in this matter would
be a great step forward as
representative mooney has said
encouraging collaboration between
districts and charter schools
is another great
step forward in opening that door it's
one of the ways i think it's very rare
but one way that this may benefit the
districts is if you have a district with
a number of charter schools
in that district and they're applying
for the bond they put it forward
they may gain additional support if
they're able to accept some of the
smaller construction needs that perhaps
the charter schools are putting forward
as well
you have a lot of charter school parents
in those districts who would be voting
the point about
funding
going towards facility instead of
programming i can speak to that
having worked in a charter school and
opened several and working with a number
of them out there
it's such an issue
38 that's what they're given and trying
to find funding for any improvement much
less purchasing a building is incredibly
hard typically it comes from donations
or you have to take it away from
something else that's happening in the
school which is necessary for the kiddos
so that's my testimony thank you so much
if you have any questions i'm happy to
answer them thank you very much are
there questions representative moffatt
thank you mr thank you for being here so
uh i'll preface my question with with a
quick
description of i'm from grofton and uh
grofton had has a
catholic hall that had classrooms in it
and for a period of time the district
the the public school district uh used
something in some fashion rented the
space and the catholic coffin
and kindergarten and first graders were
educated there in fact dr caroline who
often comes here was went to school in
that catholic for a while in that
catholic building so my question
is
with regard to
mutual potential mutual use of a
potential structure that may be uh built
and i know you're in the charter school
world so my
my question is if this were to move
forward
it would the
do we need to look at this as mutually
exclusive in terms of use of of these
school buildings or could both a public
district in a charter district use the
same space
if i understand your question correctly
it would be
looking at the
space that has been funded by a bond
from
one of these schools or from both coming
forward to be used for both entities
i
i don't think that would be a problem
but i would really
prefer to have mr phillips or
thank you so
to your knowledge you can't cite any
existing scenarios or or models that are
out there where uh
space is shared between public schools
and public charter schools you you don't
have any examples of that i don't have
any off the top of my head where they're
sharing the actual building i believe we
have
a few one or two maybe i don't have the
exact number of charter schools that may
be
in a public school building as a result
of hv 278 perhaps renting space
but the only
case that i can think of would be
i think it's a little different it would
be a charter school that
rents space from a community college
okay thank you
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you very much and our last pink card on
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the opportunity to be here
my name is bob best i'm from merrimack i
support hb 1402
i'm an attorney with soloway and hollis
and provide legal advice to a number of
charter schools and also
legal advice or been involved with a
number of the bond issues through the
state's three bonding authorities
so
i don't know a lot about municipal
bonding i won't talk a lot about that
but a little bit about
some other types of bonds that are
issued where there may be some parallels
and some opportunities
but first start with the importance to
charter schools of this
you know new hampshire has
you know long had its statute that
created charter schools and supports
them
and creates some funding for them for
their operations the 7 300 dollars that
come per student um you know helps to
pay the salaries for the teachers and
administrators and books and computers
and things um
and then there's the
federal grants for the startup programs
and obviously that helps out a lot but
those federal grants don't provide any
aid for the buildings they're not
allowed to be used for capital expenses
so uh you're certainly left with this
question if you're going to operate
charter school
where do you get the building where does
it come from and
for the sake of size or scope
a a school building that would have a
300 student capacity is probably
something like a three to five million
dollar building
and that funding's got to come from
somewhere um traditionally it's been
leased i think we heard last week that
there's some one or two or three charter
schools that actually own their
buildings
and so you lease quite a lot of them but
obviously renting from somebody else
is not as efficient a way to deal with
it as to actually own the building and
and build it and construct it so
bond funding is one avenue to do that um
lisa not let me say the building aid
that we talked about last week is an
avenue to do that you know and there's
some other opportunities when it comes
to the bond funding and this idea of
creating a dialogue with the school
district
and allowing them the option to include
it or not that doesn't in any way
obligate the school district to say we
will pay your bonds for you or we'll pay
them back for you
you can be included in a bond issue and
have an agreement that says the charter
school pays back the bonds that that it
seeks
you can have an agreement that says
agreement with the bond buyer that says
that x part of these bonds or the series
b piece of the bonds are only payable
from revenues of the charter school very
common in the hefa bonds and other state
authority bonds that are issued
these are
you know not grants from taxpayer money
these are loans from some bond buyer and
they get paid back and you know it's up
to the school district and the charter
school to figure out what are the terms
between them that the school district
finds acceptable that might make the
school district willing to say yes you
can be a part of my effort
and if the school district isn't
satisfied with those terms
as you've heard from other testimony
they can certainly say no but those
terms can certainly obligate the charter
school it could mortgage the charter
schools building uh to pay for or answer
for the bonds
it obviously has to land in a place
where somebody wants to buy the bonds
at the interest rate that they pay and
that work that depends on credit
worthiness
and security and all the kinds of
questions that normal loans are sort of
house mortgages bonds are complicated
forms but they're just mortgages they're
just loans
and and credit worthiness is is what
bond buyers consider
and all of those kinds of things can be
tackled there's no circumstance where
any school district would be obligated
against their will to take on somebody
else's responsibility um i think that
the bill certainly allows the school
district to do that but i don't think
anyone really has any practical belief
that a school district is going to say
yes i'll borrow you know
money for you and and we'll pay it back
you don't have to um i don't think
that's a dialogue anybody expects
um so there's there's certainly that
opportunity um for uh the protections
that everybody's talking about who owns
the building how does this get paid back
how's the school district not at risk
how are the taxpayers not at risk all of
those things can be solved um they're
solved every day in the bonds that are
issued by the three
state-run bonding authorities
um
and then as to whether there's an
opportunity to share a building or the
senate bill
house bill 278 i think is the number
from last year that made gave the
districts the first dibs on the
buildings um that's the first dib to you
know buy it or rent it it doesn't mean
that the school the charter school gets
the leftover building for free but even
if they did uh
and they had a building that was
available that a school district didn't
want anymore
that building probably is in need of
some things
which is probably why the school
district decided they didn't want to use
that building anymore so it may be that
even if you were able to get access to a
building through that bill
you need to do a bond issue or a loan or
something to modernize the building to
bring it up to code to
you know install sort of all of the
internet
features and now with covid dealing with
hvac and all of the ionic whatever
that's in the air vents to make sure
you're killing all the viruses that go
through the air vents and security and
all the needs for that you might you
might have a building that you um even
acquired for free that needs a million
dollars worth of upgrades
just because of
the fact that it was a building this
tired building that the school district
was ready to pass along
you could still be in a position where
you need both a benefit of 278 and some
other avenue to make use of a building
like that
i don't think that there's any reason
why schools and charter schools couldn't
share space if they chose to
i think that there are a couple of
charter schools that are actually
district sponsored charter schools i
don't know all the details of that so i
don't want to necessarily go down that
rabbit hole and try to answer questions
about how that works
but i think that obviously if they're a
district sponsored school
the district's got ownership of the
charter schools property already
so those kinds of patent solutions have
already been established
so
two messages very important for charter
schools to have a source of funding for
buildings without buildings um you know
we're just not going to have the kind of
proliferation of charter schools right
now there's a handful of uh very
generous donors who support the
provision of buildings to charter
schools
but as we've talked about many times
relying on the generosity of a handful
of people who are able to do so isn't a
way to
finance a public
school offering
second message is as to all the
mechanics and logistics that people are
concerned about all of those things can
be worked out and all of those things
can be worked out in a way where the
school district first of all can has
complete discretion on what to do and
complete protection
um so that they're not at risk or that
they're not required to tax their
uh citizens to pay back a charter
school's bonds
i'm glad to answer any questions anybody
has
uh yes i i have a question for i guess
you and others that have testified today
we have in the state what we call a
school building authority
the school building authority as i read
upon the receipt of a report from the
authority containing a recommendation
that bonds or notes of a school district
should be guaranteed by the state
why is it that this legislation is
trying to
drive these bonds through the school
district rather than the state which has
authority to issue bonds up to not to
exceed 95 million dollars
you know i don't know the ins and outs
of exactly the way the state deals with
its bonding directly where the state is
responsible for the bonds or even where
the school districts are
my experience with those is that the um
the three bonding authorities where the
state is explicitly not obligated on the
bonds and that's why i bring that
message as to how that could be the case
with charter schools as far as how it
works where there's some recommendation
of a committee that the state support
that funding
i honestly don't know enough about that
to offer any comment that's useful thank
you
question representative waltz
thank you
so you said that you know a lot about
the bonding market given the lack of
resources that these charter schools
have and given that they're not
guaranteed by a state or a city wouldn't
the market just consider these junk
bonds
so
whether the market would do that or not
or whether the market would even buy the
bonds um
when there's a when there's a
bond offering through one of the bonding
authorities at the state
the buyer is sort of identified buyer of
those bonds and the rates and the terms
and all of that are lined up by the
borrower before they're even brought to
the authority so we know that citizens
bank is going to buy all of the bonds
for a particular issue or you name the
bank
and if the borrower can't find a bank or
a lender that's willing to offer and buy
those bonds
the authority nothing happens the bonds
could be issued but nobody's going to
purchase them and nobody got any money
and
you know essentially the
deal doesn't obligate anybody to
anything because
um it's like applying for a car loan and
then getting turned down
you don't have a loan
go ahead
so i don't understand how you're saying
that it's all lined up ahead of time
we're in the bond market all the time
buying bonds and you buy municipal bonds
you can buy all kinds of bonds issued by
governmental entities what do you mean
that they would be only only go to
market if they're picked up by a bank of
course there's other kinds of bonds out
there that aren't picked up by a bank
but they are issued by governmental
authorities sure um there are obviously
private placement and public placement
bonds i didn't mean to misspeak about
that
the private the public placement bonds
i'm sorry the
public offerings of bonds are done
through a bond trustee who is doing that
same level of evaluation about the
quality of the bonds and are they rated
and moody's and all of that kind of
thing and ultimately if somebody doesn't
buy the bonds because they believe that
they're rated wrong or that they're high
risk or something like that again it's
just a loan that didn't go through
representative porter
thank you mr chairman just very quickly
my understanding if this went through
and the
charter was responsible for paying back
the bond you talked about credit rating
if the charter defaulted on the bond
would that negatively impact the credit
rating of the school for future bonds
the school district for future bonds
just a simple yes or no is all i need
it's a great question and i think it
depends i know that you want yes or no
if the school district and the charter
school
arranged some of that financing the way
that it's done on a state level it would
not affect the state's credit rating
which is similar to the
bonds that are offered through business
finance authority and the housing
finance authority they don't affect the
state of new hampshire's credit rating
no i was talking about the school
district's credit rating sure and that's
what i mean is that within the documents
of the way the bond issue's done there's
ways to arrange it so that it doesn't
affect the school district's credit
rating
but whether the school district and the
charter school would
do all of those things is up to them to
achieve
thank you
are there further questions from the
committee
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much attorney best
i'm trying to find the answer to this
but it but it's not jumping out at me
but was wondering if um
in towns that have adopted the official
ballot law sb2
if uh bond um articles can be changed at
deliberative sessions
oh boy you're way out of my scope the
skills there i don't know i wish i knew
the answer i don't all right no worries
thanks thank you uh further questions
maxine thank you very much
not having any further cards on this one
we will close this hearing and we'll
start the next hearing up in about five
minutes
you
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
next bill and the next bill is
1605 requiring saus to maintain a report
on the five-year projection of future
enrollments
is griffin petrie emerick
do we have any people signed up to speak
honorable mr craig
bob
are you here to speak on this one
yeah i i don't see any cards so so
quickly introduce it
and then we'll
thank you mr chairman members education
committee since the prime sponsor is not
here i'm introducing house bill 1605
this bill requires school administrative
units annual report to school districts
the five-year projection of future
enrollments within a school
administration unit including cost
per inf
cost per student information
the crime and repealed in 2020 25.
so
one quick one of the represent
does the litchfield district already do
this
i'm not sure i'll find out
friday when saturday when we have a
deliberative session okay i'd be
surprised if they're not maintaining a
projection so thanks okay we have one
speaker on that we have becky wilson
from the new hampshire school boards
association
good morning morning chairman laden
members of the committee thanks for
hearing my testimony today i will be
expedient because i know you have quite
a few people for the next hearing
i did submit some comments and writing
already to the committee around this
bill
we are in opposition of this bill we
feel like that school boards already do
an extraordinary job and take
extraordinary care to try to be mindful
of the impacts not only on the students
when they're developing the budget but
on the local taxpayers in their
community there are multiple
opportunities for community members to
engage in the budget development process
and to adjust the operating budget of
the school as they go through these
budget processes each year
the inflation rate annually is not
published until january of the following
year most of your school districts
budgets have been worked on since
october at that point
to require districts to have to make
cuts or
develop a plan somehow to reduce the
operating budget that the town has
already had multiple opportunities to
weigh in on seems
like a very large burden that would
create a lot of
discourse with the school districts in
terms of trying to
cut programs that have already been
budgeted for for the following year
will not read my entire testimony but on
top of that you know this bill also
seems to require that if you were going
to present a budget to the town for a
vote or a deliberative session that was
um had a higher rate of than the current
inflation rate that you would have to
then present this plan to for cuts and
or for consolidation
and there's been other bills before this
committee to
dissolve consolidation so it seems a
little confusing quite honestly to
expect districts to be able to do that
and enrollment is not the only driver of
a school district budget it is an
important driver and most districts do
maintain to the best of their ability
some sort of enrollment trends that they
can look at when they're creating these
budgets that's why sometimes there's
five second grades one year and three
the following year but there are a
number of options now for families
in terms of how to educate their
children in this state and it creates
some difficulty when you're trying as a
school district to predict your
enrollment
there's no notification requirement for
the school district to be told if
students are moving into an old-school
situation or an efa situation
there are no guard rails in terms of
districts being able to predict which
students will enter the school district
even using the town report which i know
a lot of districts do that to look at
the number of live births for a given
year and try to predict when those
students will enter the system so
with that i'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
questions for becky wilson
from the school boards association not
the next bill on the docket for today is
hb 1663 relative to requirements for
we need to have a representative in here
i have not seen an amendment in fact
there is no amendment that's a committee
amendment until it's presented by a
committee member so a lot of people can
draw up amendments i'm not interested in
that i'm interested only in the bill
okay thank you
i just
have some guidelines for how we're going
i don't want to have a lot of
duplication in what you're saying you
know if we are we're going to have to
get down to time limits and it might
even get down to like a minute a person
so that if you're
everybody has a story i understand that
we appreciate the story but if the story
is on the same vein
don't give it
if it's already been given
so please follow the rules or else we
will immediately put in time constraints
and in some committees where that's
occurred
the hearing is stopped
go ahead and i'd like to represent a
welcome representative uh leon here for
introducing this bill thank you
good morning
thank you for having me here today for
the record i am erica leon representing
rockingham six which is dairy
i come before you today in order to
address ambu ambiguities and
difficulties in the current home
education law
they have impacted our communities and
in particular families that are
struggling to find a safe and nurturing
education for their children during
these last two years of covid
these changes don't impact the taxpayers
and the guidance provided to schools and
their interactions with homeschoolers is
focused on equity
however the greatest impact on equity is
in a change to the annual assessment
language to be more inclusive of our
large and growing special education
homeschooling community and those with
learning loss before they chose to
educate at home under rsa 193a
section 1 addresses equal access which
has been proven to be a significant
challenge one that others here such as
amanda whedon the special needs
homeschooling representative on hiac
will address later in her testimony
this section changes may to shell in
regards to school boards adopting a
policy regarding participation in equal
access
i believe many of the problems we've
seen this year aren't because they don't
want to provide this access but because
they don't know how so finding the 30
districts that don't have a policy and
having them put one on the books would
be very helpful so that people know the
rules
section 2 provides a more complete
definition of how education is delivered
at home
as many parents seek out specialists or
workshop experiences to enhance
educational opportunities and it also
removes some words that have created a
lot of confusion
section 3 addresses notification and in
particular confusion about when a family
that moves out of district needs to
notify and whom
this essentially provides a framework
that notifying through the dis well it
establishes the existing framework and
puts it into the law not the rules that
people don't know to look for especially
as a new homeschooler it makes it clear
that notifying through the district or a
non-public school is statewide so if you
move within the state you're covered but
if you notify a local school district if
you move from that district you tell
them that you've moved and then you
notify the new district
it's current and as i said it's in the
rules but especially our new homeschool
parents don't even know that there's
home school rules
i do have some language that i can offer
that that does have some clarifications
because admittedly some of that language
is clunky so i have some to offer but i
know it comes through the committee i
just wanted to try and fix my own
mistakes instead of putting all that
burden on you
section 4 is the major equity issue here
and i want to be clear that we know
exactly who we're discussing today
this is the only bill in front of the
committee this year
that deals with 193 a homeschoolers
these are the classic homeschoolers the
ones we've always known before this new
efa program those ones are regulated
separately under another section
these are the families that pay their
property taxes to support their public
school
but don't send their kids there and they
take the time money and effort to
educate their kids themselves at home
with whatever specialist they they work
with
and do it at their own expense without
taking a penny from the taxpayers
they want to do everything right and
these are the families that not only
want to know what the laws are but they
want to make sure that they're clear so
they aren't making a mistake
these parents take education and
accuracy seriously
so
fixing this language to make it easier
to follow would be a huge benefit for
them so that instead of trying to figure
out the intricacies of our laws and
rules they can focus on educating their
children
now some of these students learn and
test well above grade level you'll hear
testimony from the national home
education research institute about the
tremendous performance of homeschoolers
if advanced students want to use
national assessments that are two or
three years ahead just to find the weak
spots do they have to take one at grade
level to show that they can meet these
standards and then we have other
students that don't test well
or maybe they're really far ahead in
reading but math is hard for them and
instead of trying to advance them
they're digging in and building those
foundations even if it's at a slower
pace if their math score is 20th
percentile and their reading is 99th
percentile
do we average it the law is silent and
it leads to a lot of fear and confusion
removing that 40th percentile would be
consistent with most of the other states
in this country and even more
importantly it's consistent with every
single funded student in the state
all of the taxpayer-funded students
not a single one of them has to hit a
certain score
yet we ask that of our
entirely self-funded homeschoolers
so section 5 addresses a long-standing
issue but with covet it's even more
important we had a lot of families that
never wanted to leave their public
school but either because they didn't
like the masks or
they thought the risk even with masks
was too high
they chose to step out of the public
school until they were comfortable
returning some of these families have
been asked for a portfolio to go back
into third grade
the language was clucky i have a better
section to offer to suggest it in but i
know i'm not introducing the amendments
so that we can leave to later
and also just discussing the rules doing
rules changes
everything that's in the rules for
homeschooling is already in the law
it's redundant it has some clarification
that people look to but all of the
important points are already in the law
so to summarize today we're talking
about the unfunded 193a homeschoolers
who subsidize the education of their
neighbors while not taking a penny of
taxpayer money to educate their children
these families invest time effort and
their own money into providing the best
individualized education for their kids
these families look closely to the law
because they are conscientious and want
the best for their kids
and these students these unfunded 193a
homeschoolers currently have to fight
for equal access in public schools
stress about whether tapping subject
matter experts in group workshops for
more than 50 percent of their
educational time is okay
and how to handle notifications if they
move whether they need to worry about
how they're demonstrating reasonable
academic proficiency standards that are
more strict than any other student
and about whether their students
replaced with their age peers if they do
go back to the public classroom that
they had left due to covid
i urge you to aggress address these
current concerns thank you and i'll take
questions thank you very much
representative are there questions from
the committee representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um just so that we're clear we're
talking in your
legislation about
homeschoolers
not
home parents who are homeschooling with
an efa account they are a separate
attendance category as i understand it
is that correct that is correct these
are the people who are 193a
homeschoolers there was already a method
last year with the efa accounts there
was a new section of law created for efa
students regardless of whether they're
educated in a private school
at home or any of these other
combinations they have an entirely
different section of law
and unless they gave up the efa they
would not touch the law we're looking at
today these are the people who do not
want the state money
and are very happy to do it on their own
and are very happy to have a separate
section of law
thank you further questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
like to invite uh robert clegg
honorable
senator cling
it's been a few years since you've been
hit the button there great thanks
you can't train a senator i'm sorry
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i know for the last few days
you've been dealing a lot with the
education freedom account
and i just want to help point out that
this bill is not about the efa program
it instead is specific to homeschool
students and it's governed by 193a
and as the previous speaker said these
are the people that don't want the state
money
what i'm going to do is i was asked by
dr brian ray to read his statement
for the benefit of all the people who
watch you on on camera
i usually watch you on camera myself
it's very brief and i'll go fast
honorable legislators thank you for
allowing my testimony on hb 1663.
my name is brian ray i have a phd in
science education ms in zoology
bsn biology and i'm a former certified
teacher in public and private schools
i've also been a professor at the
graduate and undergraduate university
levels in the fields of education
science and research
i have done research on the homeschool
movement for about 37 years and i'm
president of the national home education
research institute in salem oregon
40 years of research studies by various
scholars show that homeschool students
typically outperform public school
students by 15 to 30 percentile points
on standardized academic achievement
tests
the majority of research also shows that
the home educated or developing socially
and emotionally better than the public
school and the home school do as well or
better than the conventionally schooled
in adulthood in various fears of living
nevertheless just as some public schools
and private school students score below
average on achievement test
whether that means 10th 20th or 39th
percentile
so do some homeschool students current
state law states that
current law states that a homeschool
student must score at or above 40th
percentile
it's crucial to note that at about 39
percent of all public schools students
score below the 40th percentile on
nationally normed achievement tests
yes 39 of public school students by
definition score below the 40 percentile
permit me to explain a few main reasons
why the mention and law of any cut off
test score
with regard to home schooling is wrong
first it is discriminatory practice
toward homeschooling
as a legal private educational opinion
to be equitable if there is to be a
cutoff score for being free to continue
in homeschooling then there should also
be the same cut off school score
for being allowed to continue in public
school and private schools
regardless of whether they are religious
or secular independent
but there is no cutoff score for a
student to continue in the public school
or in private institutional school
neither state law nor public school
teachers nor teachers unions are arguing
that there should be a cut off score of
the 40th percentile for public school
students and that 39 percent of public
school students
should be mandated to attend private
schools or homeschooling
second there is no sound
pedagogical
reason to have different that is lower
standards for public schooling and
private schooling as compared to private
homeschooling
this is especially true in light of the
fact that such a large portion of public
school students have been found to be
below proficient
on the national naep testing program
and when so many public school students
have shown such little educational
growth over the past two years
third such a cut-off score for
homeschooling or any kind of schooling
ignores the reality that there will
always be a given percent of students
whether public schooled private schooled
or homeschooled below any given
percentile cut-off point
the important thing in education is not
whether a student is below point x or y
on a standardized test
but whether the student is making
appropriate educational progress
a homeschool student or a public school
a private school student moving from the
20th percentile one year to the 27th
percentile
might indicate tremendous growth and
learning
all educators should know this
fourth and finally
research shows that the degree of state
control and regulation of homeschooling
is not related to an academic
achievement
achievement test scores of home school
students in state with higher
regulations are the same as states with
lesser regulations
thank you for allowing me to speak brian
ray and mr chairman there is a set of
references and i will pass out enough i
believe for the whole committee um
i take questions but i'm not sure i'm
smart enough to answer any
i won't comment on that
thank you uh are there any questions
from the committee
good morning my name is michelle avell
and it's a pleasure to be back in the
house education committee it's been a
while so nice to see you again
in the interest of time i'm going to
abbreviate my comments i have copies
that i'll distribute to the committee
afterwards i'll even email them to you
so you can see the hyperlinks and check
out the research for yourself
my name is michelle lavelle and i am the
director and a co-founder of granite
state home educators gsag is an
all-volunteer
501 c 4 non-profit
we have approximately 6 000 members
around the state
and 9 social media accounts with over 14
000 participants
gshe supports 1663 because it addresses
important aspects of home education
statute
it resolves some housekeeping
inconsistencies
and gives parity to homeschoolers
relative to students in other
educational programs
and i can't emphasize enough
this bill impacts unfunded homeschoolers
students
that follow 193a not those participating
in education freedom accounts that are
governed by 194f
we need to make that distinction clear
because i've heard in other testimonies
and discussions a real confusion on that
point so these are the unfunded
traditional homeschoolers here
in the interest of time i'm going to
skip significant sections and go right
to part four that removes the
unequitable academic achievement
thresholds and provides protections for
home educated students with special
education differences
currently unfunded homeschooled students
are the only educational pathway that
has individual student academic
achievement requirements written into
state law
the current home education statute says
that a child must show quote progress
commensurate with age and ability
it further states that if a family uses
a standardized test for the annual
assessment that the child must achieve a
composite score at or above the 40th
percentile to demonstrate academic
proficiency
achievement at or above the 40th
percentile means that 39 percent of
students fail automatically
this standard is unique to unfunded home
educated children
by comparison
trend to students who are enrolled in
the recovering bright future program and
are funded by a six million dollar
federal grant may opt out of the
statewide assessments like their public
school peers and have no academic
achievement
standard
funded education freedom account
students have no performance requirement
yet have an average of forty five
hundred dollars of stat state adequacy
money follow the child
students participating in town tuition
programs also have no academic
achievement requirement in statute and
have local tax money follow them to an
out of district or private school
students in public schools cost an
average of 18 thousand dollars yet do
not have individual academic achievement
requirements in statute
just like other states new hampshire's
public schools struggled with learning
loss in 2020 due to the pandemic
however the statewide achievement scores
indicate generally low proficiency
across all three subject areas well
before clovid was a factor
according to state statute rsa 193 193-h
colon 2 public schools districts were
required to have quote
all pupils at the proficient level or
above on the statewide assessment by the
2018-19 school year
that benchmark was not achieved in my
written remarks you will see what the
scores have been over the last six years
in addition
public school students may opt out of
the statewide assessment for rsa 193-c
colon 6. home educated students are
required to do some kind of annual
assessment and do not have an opt-out
choice
the academic achievement on a
standardized test of the 40th percentile
or above is clearly an unequitable
requirement particularly given
that home educated students do not
receive federal state or local dollars
1663 also seeks to protect homeschooled
students who have special education
challenges
they are a fast-growing segment of the
homeschool community and they need clear
protection stated in the law
the current statute says progress
commensurate with age and ability
hb 1663 provides language that
acknowledges and protects those students
who have disabilities by explicitly
taking their differences into
consideration for their annual
assessment
note that the proposed changes to rsa
193a colon six do not remove the annual
assessment requirement home educated
students are still required to
administer some type of assessment and
the options remain the same a
standardized test an evaluation by an
education professional who either has
certification or is currently teaching
in one of new hampshire's private
schools or another agreed upon method
these are not altered in hb 1663
in closing please support thousands of
unfunded home educated students in past
homeschoolers are not asking for funding
services or special favors we simply
want some important details cleaned up
in the statute
privacy explicit protection for our
special ed children and a level playing
field please give 1663 a not to pass
vote and with that i'll take any
questions thank you very much michelle
are there questions
from the committee
thank you very much the next uh person
is uh
abigail
bellmore
can you put if there's a when it comes
on red you're you're live there you go
abigail belmore from chester new
hampshire i'm in support of the bill i
will be sending an email to all the
committee mentors i'm going to be short
and sweet
i am in support of the bill i am in
support of this bill by changing the
wordage in several phrases throughout
the home school law
to clarify and make it easier for
homeschool families to read the letter
of the law and also give us a
documentation to present to our school
a public access to classes that would
enrich our students
stating that homeschoolers are being
held at a higher standard than regular
public schools needs to go and
learning disabilities need to be held at
a level which the children learn with
that disability
returning students to the public school
needs to be
that are being discriminated because
they are homeschooled either by short or
long term
need to be allowed to enter at their
grade in level of age
not
on factors that the school feels that
they need to be in
notifications need to be clear
where we're sending them and how we are
sending them whether we are beginning or
ending our public edu our home school
education whether we're sending it to a
public or to the state
a lot of confusion happens
thank you are there questions for the
presenter
thank you very much
welcome again sarah
all right thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
for the opportunity to provide testimony
today
my name is sarah scott and i'm the
director of grassroots operations for
americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire
and on behalf of americans for
prosperity new hampshire and our
activists all across the state
i urge you to support house bill 1663
a bill which clarifies the requirements
for home educated students
and this legislation really does make
several very important clarifications
so first it ensures that each of the
districts shall have a policy in place
for home educated students who
participate in classes and
extracurriculars
state law
already requires that these districts
allow these students to participate but
there is some confusion among some
districts as to what that policy looks
like
so this bill would just clarify that and
make sure that school educators
and staff there would have a clear
understanding
of how that policy works
and i think that this bill would really
guarantee that students are not left
waiting if they're wishing to
participate in classes or
extracurriculars there was at least one
instance over the past year where a
district was unclear on how these
students were to be integrated
and there was time that the student is
sitting there waiting to participate
i just wanted to kind of clarify that i
know firsthand the importance of giving
these home educated students access to
the classes and the extracurriculars
between my two sisters and i we were
homeschooled public school private
school we did all the different options
at one point or another
and throughout the time that we were
home educated
i participated in classes at the local
public school i did foreign languages
gym art class while my sisters
participated in various sports and
without
the opportunity to take these classes i
think our education would have been
a lot different
and so i really think it's important
that we make sure that we have a policy
amongst each district for how these
students can participate
so next this bill clarifies that home
education must be provided coordinated
or directed by a parent
over the last five to ten years
education has really become more
unbundled than ever before we're seeing
parents take advantage of opportunities
that we haven't seen before
and so this legislation makes it clear
that parents don't need to be the only
educator in their child's education
and then just lastly this bill makes
certain that home educated students with
disabilities are evaluated with the same
standards as children with similar
disabilities that are in a traditional
school setting
this is a straightforward and reasonable
expectation that i think we can all
agree makes sense
these students should absolutely not be
held to a higher level of assessment
than a student in a more traditional
setting so it's for these reasons that
we ask you to support the passage of
this legislation
thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
so again i'm not quite as familiar with
this as some people and i've been
sitting here reading it and what i see
is that there's a choice among parents
we are not mandating that they take a
standardized test and score forty
percent there's a choice so if a parent
is concerned about the forty percent
would they have a choice of using an
alternative method to determine
competency
uh thank you for the question yes there
is a choice a lot of parents do like to
use the standardized assessments because
it's easier for them to track their
students progress over the course of the
any further questions
thank you
we have a card from j.r hole
previously representative whole
at one time sat on the education
committee
is it good
okay
for the record representative hall uh
state rep um from 2010 to
sat on this committee my first term
i am here in support of this bill with
the idea that some changes need to be
to me need to be made
for the record my wife and i have
homeschooled our children from
kindergarten through grade 12 for the
oldest two um grade 10
for my daughter and grade seven for my
my youngest son
um i'm gonna as a brief amount of
testimony my oldest two one has a 392 at
unh is paying his own way through school
without help from parents without school
debt my second child
is a sophomore has a 4-0 he's paying his
own way through school while he's
working a job
at manchester community
and
clearly homeschool parents can do a good
job
section one and two are great of this
bill i love that um i have i echo the
concerns about the 40th percentile right
because the 40th percentile as someone
else pointed out means 39 of the
students in in this average distribution
would be below that level
um
statistically speaking that's that's not
a good percentage and and not everybody
is going to be capable at that level
just because of their
their
natural abilities
so
um i understand there may be an
amendment um coming forward at some
point um it's the representative leon
amendment i i just briefly read through
it just now i saw no issues with that
amendment i am in support of those
changes
um
i am concerned about the fact that um as
parents move from district to district
the notification issues get pretty ugly
and squirrely
um if you've notified your prior one now
you gotta notify your your new one at
one point we were looking at whether you
even need some level of notification um
because if you notify the town and then
you move to another town right there it
just gets ugly um at some point i'm not
sure that notification is necessary um
but that's that's not this bill and
that's for another day
okay i would ask that you would support
it with the changes that were proposed
by representative leon and
um that ends my tone testimony i'll ask
take any questions if there are any
thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative waltz
would you believe that the committee
does not have an amendment from
representative land so we have no idea
referencing no
no
amendment has been presented okay we
don't accept it and
tell it comes from a member on the
committee okay um have you been have you
guys been provided a copy of that
amendment no no at all okay no um i will
make sure that i email the secretary at
least that and hopefully one of you guys
will introduce it at the executive
session thank you thank you
further questions not seeing thank you
very much
we have amanda
whedon
my name is amanda whedon and i'm a home
educator here in new hampshire
i think that this is the most important
descriptor in the list of roles i'm
about to share because this bill
directly affects me and my family
i'm a leader co-founder and board member
of granite state home educators the most
active and supportive homeschool
community in new hampshire
a handful of us spend an inordinate
amount of time in our network network of
facebook groups supporting
educating and advocating for
homeschoolers in new hampshire
we maintain the premier website for
resources in our great state host
countless info sessions events meetups
we mentor encourage and assist home
educators of all kinds online and in
person
i'm also a leader in christian home
educators of new hampshire in southern
maine formerly seacoast christian home
educators we made the move during the
pandemic to a statewide
non-denominational christian support
group
and at just shy of a thousand members
we're extremely active politically and
in our local communities across new
hampshire
i'm the special needs homeschooling
representative on hiac the home
education advisory council
appointed by the commissioner
it is my job to remain keenly aware of
legislation guidelines issues and
concerns that involve special needs
homeschoolers and to represent the best
interests of special needs homeschoolers
to the public
the commissioner the department of
education and the legislature
i'm a special needs homeschooling
advocate
i spend my free time counseling
supporting and encouraging special needs
homeschooling families
i create content for workshops my
youtube channel and granite state home
educators website
blog and newsletter
i hoard curriculum i compile lists and
share everything i know with anyone who
needs help
i do info sessions on the home school
law in new
hampshire
i make phone calls to public school
superintendents and principals i go to
school board meetings i email
legislators
i created the only special needs
inclusive co-op for homeschoolers in new
hampshire last september
i use my sphere of influence to help
build a homeschool community that is
strong that is fierce that is here and
that is mobilized
i'm a veteran homeschool mom
i homeschool four children ages 15 to
six
and i'm a special needs homeschool mom
and i'm here testifying because
all of this makes me an expert
now i fully realize that there are
people who probably signed in on this
bill who might be here today to testify
as well who not only are not home
schoolers but probably don't know the
first thing about homeschooling or the
home school law in new hampshire
there are organizations that saw home
education committee and home education
probably without even reading
i'm not a public school parent i'm not
part of a teacher's union i'm not an
educational lobbyist i am an expert
in home education in new hampshire and
i've spent years earning the privilege
to speak here today on behalf of the
homeschool community
a brief explanation of this bill should
clear up any misgivings one might have
as to whether or not
hb1663 is needed necessary
or even relevant
we have five objectives in this bill
this bill requires school boards to
adopt an equal access policy it's a
simple change of the word may
to shall
i want to make sure that you understand
what equal access means and what it
means to this bill
the current law states that home
educated students have the right to
curricular and co-curricular activities
at their local sau
public schools may not treat
homeschoolers any differently than
enrolled students when signing up for
classes programs prom
this is current law
homeschool families pay taxes just like
public school families and this is a
legal right in new hampshire there are
dozens at least of public school
districts that either won have no
written guidelines whatsoever or two
have extremely outdated and often
therefore illegal guidelines
did you hear about that homeschool
advocate who challenged the rochester
school district
ultimately resulting in the doe taking
legal action against the district for
discriminating against homeschoolers
ask me to tell you the whole story
another time
it's exactly why this one word change is
needed
since i sacrifice my time to educate and
correct public school districts
regarding their non-existent or outdated
policies i think i know what i'm talking
about when i say
rochester's was from 1996 their policy
the law needs to be updated by changing
the word made to shall
number two removes language that could
imply home education needs approval by a
participating agency
parents direct
their child's home education period
by adding the language coordinated or
directed by for his or her
own child the law would make it
explicitly clear that it's parent
directed
and inclusive of both genders it only
the second part unless the provider is
as otherwise agreed upon by the
appropriate parties named in paragraph
two what
no
that part needs to go there's no other
appropriate parties
to agree on anything the participating
agency does not have this power legally
and the law should reflect that
number three
eliminates inconsistencies regarding who
to notify and when this is a long
overdue addition
i'm asked regularly
across all media groups
in person
on the street
in line for coffee
exactly the questions that this edition
answers
notifying agencies okay we have options
participating agency a private school
acting in that capacity the department
notifying agencies need to know if a
homeschool child moves out of state if
they move to a different district this
is a simple and clear change to the
language making it consistent
number four removes academic performance
thresholds and provides protections
for home educated students with special
ed differences
this part is my jam
this part is why i really
i'm here
brought my kids
didn't bring them in person you're
welcome
homeschoolers are the only educational
pathway
that have an individual academic
achievement requirement in statute
even though they're not supported by tax
dollars
this is mind-blowing okay
allow me to give you a quick example how
to illustrate this so
number one it's unfair number two it's
unjust this portion of the law
so we're gonna talk about donuts let's
say three kids get hired to mcdonald's
the boss tells all three kids they must
each make at least 40 donuts per shift
the first kid makes 63 but the boss
doesn't care
he didn't even ask how many they made
the second kid makes 27 and the boss
didn't ask that kid either the third kid
makes 13.
the boss asked this kid how many did you
make
and then fires that kid for not making
at least 40 donuts
is this fair is this just of course this
is a silly example about donuts and it's
easy to see why treating three kids
differently is unfair
it's easy to see that it's unjust to
fire the one kid if the boss didn't even
care about what the other kids made
now imagine this the third kid has
severe dyslexia and couldn't read the
recipe
in new hampshire homeschooled students
have the requirement of urine
assessments
none of the tweaks in this bill changes
that
parents typically choose one of two
options standardized testing or
portfolio review parents choose which
standardized test to administer who to
hire as a certified teacher
to review the child's portfolio if a
parent chooses a standardized test the
student must achieve at least 40
percentile this is written in the home
school law
it's not written in the law for public
school students
not for private school students
not for funded efa homeschool students
not for prendopods
in fact homeschoolers are the only
educational pathway that has this
academic achievement requirement but
we're not funded by tax dollars and it's
a mystery
why would unfunded traditional rsa 193a
homeschoolers be held to a higher
standard than any other educational
option
but this portion of statute it needs to
go it's unfair and it is unjust and just
like my donut example
it is unfair and unjust to treat my kids
different than the public school
children
it's discrimination
children like mine with special needs
learning disabilities and those who need
accommodations or modifications are not
able to be in compliance with this
portion of the law if i choose a
standardized test for my child's
year-end assessment
i could speak on this point for hours
since time is short
and as an expert in special needs
homeschooling i will say this
special ed homeschoolers should have
their disability expressly considered in
their annual assessment this bill
accomplishes that my last point is that
currently public schools use arbitrary
and suggest subjective means to
determine the placement for
homeschoolers
wishing to enroll re-enroll
after coming from a home education
pathway
we've stuck it out with hundreds of
families who for whatever reason decided
to temporarily homeschool their children
so as some of these families did decide
to re-enroll in public school
some of them were met with resistance
some of them were met
with
quite frankly opposition and treated
differently than kids who were
re-enrolling who were not coming from a
homeschooling traditional rsa 193a
pathway so instead of placement in
elementary and middle school by agent
address which is
typical
they were asked to provide portfolios
which we must keep as part of our
home education program and year-end
assessments
so
these children were asked for
for proof of their education no other
students are asked for that in
elementary and middle school they're
assigned their classroom by age and
address
so this bill clearly states a
non-discrimination policy if home school
students re-enroll in public school
so these five main points of the bill
are important they're long past due and
there's nothing of concern for taxpayers
let me say that again nothing of concern
for taxpayers there's nothing to object
to the fact that representative lan had
taken the time to craft this legislation
points to the need for your ought to
pass a vote
she's also a homeschool mom
and understands the importance of
clearly updating this statute to reflect
consistent
equitable treatment under the law
in closing i'd like to thank you members
of the house education committee for
your service
and your dedication to equitable fair
just education for all new hampshire
children
thank you very much amanda are there
questions representative cordelli
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you for being here today um thank
everybody for being here today
we've had a lot of discussion
recently especially about federal idea
law
and the fact that
whether
someone leaving a public school
might lose
the ability for services provided and
mandated under idea law
as a homeschool
mom you are not covered by idea
is it i take it it is possible
for
a mother of a child
with needs to get the services that you
feel are necessary for your child
um without the benefit of federal idea
law is that correct and are there many
parents of special needs children who
are homeschooling yes absolutely
and we are one of the
um that this population has been growing
especially during the pandemic kids who
are in a public school setting their
needs were not being met due to the
nature of the mess that it was so these
kids were not being supported their ieps
their 504 plans were not being followed
either lack of staff
i mean we know so we had a surge of
homeschoolers period
but that specific population is growing
and that's not just a new hampshire
my son
um he's now 11 and he has a list of
diagnosis and he has never been outside
of my care so he's never been educated
outside of my home or underneath my
direction
and my son is thriving
he is safe
spiritually he is safe academically
he's safe
emotionally
in my care so there are many many
resources available to all homeschool
families but those that are particular
to
special needs homeschoolers and this is
again part of what i do is provide this
list to people
at home therapies most of us turn to
private therapies through private
insurance
which
tend to be a better fit for our children
because in a
home educated child is not in a public
school setting we don't need them to
perform and to stay within the
the box so to speak of a public school
setting so private
private therapies
are a better fit usually for our family
so there are scholarships there are
grants
there's
there's a whole big world out there of
curriculum
of at-home options for all different
types of therapies
and again so part of what i do is
provide those resources to these
families
and if my kid i i wish i could have
brought him today because he is a
treasure he's a joy and he deserves
thank you very much
are there further questions
representative woodcock
thank you chairman and good have
almost good afternoon
uh just a quick question i've listened
to two or three speakers already and
they're talking about the numbers of
youngsters participating in the 193
phase of the education options in new
hampshire
do you have a
not the number of social contacts or
media outlets can you tell me how many
young i was thinking about the district
transfer and all this
is is there a repository of a number or
can you tell me the number uh or does
doe have the number of students
participating in this program
in that are traditional notifying our
essay 193a homeschoolers i just want to
make sure i understand the question
so they do have a number but
to explain a little bit we went from
notifying every year in
in years past right that the law changed
so that now we notify only one time and
this is again why this legislation this
tweak here is needed because how are we
keeping track if someone moves from a
district to another district will they
notified with that district and now do
they notify again who do they tell that
they moved this needs to be addressed in
the law so there is a notification
we do need to look at that piece
aside from this tweak which will help
but the department of education really
they get a number from the participating
agencies so the private schools that act
as pas
they just get a number this is how many
notified
right so the public school enters it
into their database they also provide a
number
right so i assume the doe totals that
all together but because on the back end
of this we don't have a good system
so when a student leaves goes to another
educational option
it's muddy
go ahead just so with all the mud can we
saffron or call a number do we do you
have a a relatively accurate as a
self-professed expert here uh of what
the number is
so i would say there is not an accurate
number so the department of education
and i'm sure michelle or erica can
provide that information directly from
the commissioner of the department of
education but because of all these
things that i'm saying it's not an
accurate number okay thank you thank you
chairman
further questions yes representative
mullen
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
are there school districts
that are already
integrating home-schooled kids into
curricular and co-curricular experiences
and um
if so
are there model policies that you uh
have access to
yes so it is actually fairly common
for students to
um
to take classes it's curricular and
co-curricular so basically this is
anything
so if they want to
join an after school club if they want
to go for chemistry lab any of these
things are legally a right for taxpaying
home educated families so yes there is a
tremendous amount of homeschoolers that
utilize this kind of a la carte to
create their homeschool program
and so the experience that i have had
in dealing directly with districts is
they don't know what they don't know
okay so
the rochester district for example had
to be taken to the extreme level of
legal intervention typically when i call
or michelle or so one of us calls the
school district we speak to them and let
them know this law is here let me email
you this law and give me a call and we
can go over it they honestly either
don't know
they really just don't know or
it's so
outdated and they don't know how to
update it
so
this part of
this updating of the law that's why this
is so important we want the public
schools to have an easier
time they don't want me calling them
saying you guys this is from 20 years
ago nobody wants that we want everybody
to be on the same page right so that
they know
this is the law this is how we
accomplish the law there isn't a
standard set of guidelines um that is
something that i think would be amazing
because again the wording
they just don't know what they don't
know i do know for a fact that the
rochester school district did legally
have to update their policy so they have
one and it's a great place to start
yeah thank you very much further
questions from the committee
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much for joining us this
morning and it's great to have an expert
um
to um uh to you know provide the
committee with um with information
um
sort of getting to um
to what's uh what's in in uh
home school and what's in in public
schools in particular that was one of
the things that you sort of addressed
that uh that this bill would um would
help facilitate but i was wondering if
you could comment on
whether or not
the the home school
statute 193 a colon 4
refers to the same minimum academic
standards that
that exist for public schools in 193e
so i can ask the question a different
way are our home school standards the
same held to the same minimum academic
so we have a separate set of
requirements that in many ways mirror a
public school
but our subject requirement is listed in
very plain language in the law
so our academic requirements
everything falls upon the parent
accountability falls upon the parent
and that is the way the law is written
for
homeschoolers and that is the way that
it should be
um
when you were five you were held
accountable to your mom your dad
and the same goes for education and
homeschoolers believe very strongly
that
the educational requirements need to be
followed
but also that we have the freedom to
craft
our own
child's
education but a follow-up mr chair
that's that's fine i'm not arguing with
that but are the standards the same for
homeschoolers as they are for um
for public school uh public schools or
is it different
so we are required by law to
choose a year-end assessment
and so we have options in that there are
three currently in the law two of them
are what most people choose
just to clarify i'm talking about the
minimum academic standards
so they're the same or different
we
we are a different educational pathway
than public school students and much
like private school students prendapods
or any other educational pathway
including the efa funding we have our
thank you very much are there further
questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
i'd also like to take the opportunity
here to thank all our homeschoolers that
came today i'm looking around at the
crowd in front of me and
looks like i'm seeing somebody between
the ages of two and possibly three out
there
and i've seen a toddler go out that's
probably not even to one yet or about
1.3 or something like that
and i really appreciate the way
homeschoolers are always
behaving and on task and listening
we do have one more here i didn't have
that one presented to me
however you know i just want to
compliment you on what you're doing here
and this is a unique program as it is
in our state and
it's been very successful as well
so with that i'd like to have the last
person to testify
evidently we just received this car from
yeah we need to have these up here
because now we're going to be stringing
this thing out
i am going to put a time limit on the
remaining cards absolutely
i i apologize thank you committee chair
thank you committee member i'm sorry i
didn't know that my pink card had gotten
up there uh which is why i had left the
building or left hold on one second i
want to see how many we got coming here
we are going to have to put a time
constraint on all this i will be less
than a minute
okay go for it okay my name is rusty ann
chester i am i currently live in bedford
new hampshire
my history is older than that so it's
not from the town that i currently live
in however i had two special needs
children
one was
coded severely emotionally disturbed
because that's the only way that i could
get her the services that she needed
because in the public school system
because of her iq status and she refused
to be homeschooled the other one
had significant emotional disabilities
and i can tell you right now that
um that school system wanted my severely
emoted one so they were both labeled
severely demo emotionally disturbed but
my um
my younger child had other learning
disabilities as a result of that as well
when it came time for the standardized
testing
they wanted my
child that had learning disabilities to
stay home
so that they would keep their standards
up they wanted my my child that
was exceptional to attend so they could
keep their standards up so the bottom
line is is that forcing homeschoolers to
represent that for to to do that the
school systems are already manipulating
the facts
it's time to stop
and holding homeschoolers to a standard
that we don't we're not holding our
public schools to that same standard
they've found a way around it
and that's all i have thank you very
much
other questions
thank you very much thank you i'd like
thank you guys for letting me come up
here
my name is isaac shea and i support the
hb 1663 bill because my parents
along with other homeschool parents
paying taxes shall have the same rights
for their students as public school
students to participate in the same
activities as the students
as other students our parents are paying
taxes just like everyone else
please pass the hb 1663 bill and protect
our students rights i'm here today to
represent what john holt said quote it
is the duty of citizens citizens in a
free country not to fit into society but
to make society thank you all thank you
very much
no clapping no clapping not allowed
we'll close it right down
okay adriana
about a f
full f-o-l-o
i'm i'm trying to read it correctly for
you
adrian and batafico okay thank you
adriana um hello my name is adriana
patafico and i am testifying in support
of house bill 1663.
i have lived in the great state of new
hampshire for over 20 years and during
that time
i have paid property taxes a large
portion going towards the local schools
i home educate two children however the
however over the years i have not been
able to access any materials from my
local public school
as an example two years ago my child's
laptop broke and i approached the school
requesting to borrow one for just a
short period of time
they had been advertising that they had
gotten a grant
because of the pandemic and they had
extras however as a home educator i was
denied this request
i believe that all home educated
children should have equal access to
their public schools material within
reason and equal access to the school's
classes sports and clubs
education is not a one size fits all it
is important for children to have
options to best meet their needs the
simple change of the current wording of
the law from may to shell will ensure
equal access for all children in new
hampshire
this bill also provides much-needed
protection for children with special
education challenges by allowing the
consideration in their annual assessment
um please support house bill 1663 and
thank you for the gift of your time and
consideration of this bill
thank you very much
hello and thank you for your time today
i'm entering this testimony for support
of
hb 1663 into the record would you please
not read your testimony try to condense
it or summarize it thank you
because i'm going to keep it short and
sweet because many of the salient points
were already hit upon previously
again my name is angel briston i live in
manchester new hampshire and my husband
and i home educate our daughter
and because of that we support this bill
i'm going to touch upon the salient
points for our family firstly regarding
part two the home education was designed
to be directed by the parents
it's solely our right responsibility to
educate our children and so our family
does not need to solicit
input from the participating agency so
we need that clarification that portion
that says it must be agreed upon with
the participating agency because it was
never intended that a home education
program must be intended to be agreed
upon by both parents the participating
agency serves only to acknowledge the
letter of intent and to retain the
letter and of course notify the
department of education
uh next regarding part three if our
family ever moves to another school
district we just want it clear that
we're only required to notify one
participating agency
that would be terminating our home
education program in that district and
then starting a new district we don't
want to be in violation or have some
statement violation because of the
incorrect inference that would be
required to notify more than one
participating agency
and even though it's been talked about
quite a bit i still feel like it's
really important to reiterate the
portion about the academic achievement
requirements um we are taxpayers we have
a couple of properties here in the city
and we're paying our fair share of taxes
and yet our children are being held to
our child being held to a different
standard
makes no sense that
the 40th percentile is there for
homeschooled students when there's no
other child on any of the edge of other
educational tracks all of which receive
public funding taxpayer funding again
the efas the printer
the public schools printer pods public
schools
um and the efa participants have nothing
written in content
nothing written in statute so it's just
inequitable
we don't want that for our family so
your time limit is up we've gone well
over two minutes now okay i'm giving
everybody two minutes now because it
seeks to correct these fallacies we're
in support of the bill and we request
that you please pass it thank you very
much thank you very much
uh hi my name is carrie lesage i'm a new
hampshire resident living in candia and
i appreciate you listening to my
testimony today and i'll just briefly
summarize
i'm coming strongly in support of hb
because i think it would bring some
really much needed clarity to the rules
for unfunded homeschoolers and um i
wanted to just quickly tell you three
important things about our family as
homeschoolers under 193a we're
completely unfunded by anybody besides
ourselves completely out of pocket for
our educational program
we do pay our local taxes support our
local schools very happy to do that
and lastly we have nothing to do with
the efa program
just to clarify because i know it's been
a point of confusion over the last weeks
so the reasons that i support this bill
for our family
is that it rectifies an inequitable
requirement in our current law
which that's an achievement requirement
for home-schooled students when the
similar requirement is not in place for
other educational pathways and um this
is not in my written testimony but just
in
response to a question that was asked
earlier
for those of us who choose
standardized testing at the end of each
year which our family does i kind of
prefer it for myself
no i don't ever get concerned about it
because my children happen to be people
who test well and can meet those
requirements with flying colors but if
we were if if we were in a situation
where they couldn't i could see it being
a disincentive to take a standardized
test instead and instead to choose
something else so um just throwing it
out there that i think um
sorry um
if if the requirements could be made the
same as for all the other educational
pathways it will help more homeschooling
parents to feel comfortable as well
using standardized tests if they choose
to do that as their assessment at the
end of the year
and then secondly
this bill just takes steps to clarify
that it's the parents and not the school
district administrators who are
ultimately responsible for child's
education um we take our responsibility
quite seriously and we want to make sure
that you that you know that we do so
thank you and um i would ask you to
support hb1663
okay jody underwood jody a long time
since we've seen you here sb-8 croydon
et
jody underwood i am chair of the croydon
school board i'm on the board of the
school district governance association
i have a phd in education and i have
been a school choice advocate in new
hampshire for many years as has
witnessed here
i am not going to read all of this i'm
going to try to summarize what my points
are
i do support the the proposed changes
but there are some ways in which this
bill doesn't go far enough in my opinion
um
so one is it's really easy for school
boards to lose track of what they're
supposed to be doing about what in
particular they're supposed to provide
to home school students i've been on the
board since 2010 and until i read this
bill and looked at the rsas behind it i
wasn't aware of everything we were
supposed to do i want that model policy
and i will help promulgate that around
the state um so i'm gonna go look at
rochester so thank you amanda
um
uh that that's point one and i think
it's a very serious point this is how we
learn what we're supposed to do is
what's on that that you know must do uh
list of policies so people have been
talking about the inequities of the
academic achievement
and it's not just that end of year test
that gets affected but it's also the
co-curricular and curricular activities
some kids aren't allowed to
be involved in curricular activities
because they're not meeting a certain
standard but if that's the case then
that should also be applied to the kids
who go to public schools as well that
would make it equitable so i mean for
those two reasons not to restate the
other one
i think that language should just be
removed so that it is equitable because
nobody's taking kids out of public
schools for not meeting the 40th
percentile right
um
and
so
sorry it's hard to
totally summarize i'm trying to be quick
um
so
yeah so so my another reason to remove
it is i mean the words that the phrasing
um that it only implies that homeschool
students has to have to perform at the
40th percentile there's nothing in there
that's explicit about it
um
but so that's another reason to remove
it so it's really not a statute and
there's no um consequences if they don't
there i mean there's nothing in there
it's really just a definition
um so consider that when you think about
whether to remove it or not
um but i think um maybe to overstate it
arguing over how to change a rule um
that has no consequences and is not
you know in fact clear
um
is pointless and a waste of everybody's
time really it should just be clarified
um
and
uh so that's it so please vote otp for
hb 1663 and consider making the changes
even broader
thank you for your attention
questions
thank you very much
hello i'm katie mclaughlin i live in
hampton falls i've been homeschooling
for about 12 years my oldest is about to
graduate and go to college
my youngest is six i'm a part of the
houma education advisory council and i
also
am a part of a large network on the
seacoast with a lot of families we do a
lot of co-ops and a lot of mom schools
so um it's been amazing over the last
couple of years since the pandemic to
see how many people have had to
wanted to look at all their options for
education and so i've been part of a
team of wonderful moms and dads who have
tried to catch those people who are
looking for the other options and be
just be able to gently counsel them and
give them clear guidance on what those
options are
so now that we have the efa that's one
thing and then the prenda thing we first
want to just ask you to please remember
that the 193 homeschoolers are
unfunded and we we believe we have the
right to our privacy and our liberties
to direct oversee
and provide the education for our
children as we see fit
i do like i do like the um the changing
of the words by adding that parents can
direct not only provide it but can
direct it because what i see around the
seacoast is people don't like to be
isolated and on their own they actually
do like to work with other people they
like to be social they like to look for
help
and
so people are doing that and i it's
there's nothing wrong or illegal about
asking a mom who's gifted in science to
teach science
and a parent who's gifted in another
area to teach that and they do that
freely
and
we should just make sure that that's
allowed so i like that change um and
then the last thing i just wanted to
bring up is this equal treatment i have
often heard of families and it's usually
at the high school level
going into a high school often treated
very well and allowed to go in and be
part of sports or after school
activities my kids have done that and
it's not been a problem
but it's been quite shocking to hear
schools seem to randomly decide that
they're going to
hold a family to a higher standard such
as
we will only accept your child's
progress for work for ninth grade if it
came from an accredited school
but in that same year that school
accepted kids into
that same grade 10th grade
from districts in other states or in our
state that we're not accredited so that
was an unfair standard it was quite
shocking for that family and
i think that to ask school boards to
make a policy is is not too much to ask
i think overall it's going to save
school board time it's going to save the
administration time
of the public schools it will save
parents time so they will know if they
want to access the curricular
co-curricular activities how they can go
about doing that and to know and have
confidence that they will not be ignored
and they will not be mistreated
that's about your time okay thank you
very much
my name is deborah muirs i administer
tri-city christian academy's
participating agency program so i have a
different perspective i am a home i also
homeschool my son our school is located
in somersworth i wanted to specifically
address the requirements for termination
the language needs to be changed when
parents notify through our school and
they do from all over the state
their notification remains private
we're only required to send statistics
to the state in the october report it's
inconsistent to require parents to send
termination notification to the
commissioner of education when that
office holds no record of the family
it should go to the chosen
participating agency only one of the
reasons that people choose our school is
because we respect their privacy our
letter of acknowledgement states that we
do not give out any information
without their consent
i would like to see that this bill could
clear up that inconsistency and
hopefully an amendment has been or will
be introduced to that end
thank you
thank you very much deborah
are there questions let's sing any thank
you very much
well thank you mr chairman it's great to
be back in new hampshire in this
committee room where i have been coming
for 20 years
as an advocate for homeschoolers first
as a member of the christian educators
of new hampshire
uh then
as a grafton boy
uh raised in grafton new hampshire
graduated from ascoma high school
it's pretty amazing i pinch myself
sometimes i get to travel the world
advocating for homeschooling freedom can
you imagine a boy from grafton doing
something like that
those of you who even know her crafton
is uh
my name is mike donnelly i'm a senior
counsel with hslda have a jd from boston
university
lm from london school of economics
admitted to the bars of new hampshire
massachusetts west virginia d.c
i'm even a professor of law i teach
constitutional a lot of patrick henry
college students and
international criminal law to
regent law school students
my mom hi mom
she'd be proud
maybe she's even watching in grafton she
still lives there we're an advocacy
organization with over 107 000 member
families who represent their interests
and other like-minded homeschoolers and
i just want to say this i get to travel
to a lot of capitals in my job
and i know that
you are asked to do more than any other
legislators in any other
uh
elected body in the world for
well no
never has been so much asked for so many
and given so little i know how much you
don't make so i just want to commend you
for your citizen service your true
statesman and true citizen statement so
just real quick hit on a couple things
here you've heard about how
homeschooling is just
exploded in terms of growth and i think
it's really great that you're looking at
improving the homeschool law here and i
want to support the ideas contained in
representative leon's
proposed bill here hb1663 some great
ideas there are a few additional ideas i
think that could um could be added to it
and i believe she has prepared an
amendment and i want to tell you that
with those changes made by that
amendment
uh our organization would support
uh hb 1663 and i know you don't have it
but i think you will soon hopefully one
of you will introduce it and we would
support that
this bill would make make it easier for
current homeschoolers new homeschoolers
public administration officials like the
department of education getting less
information providing clarity to
superintendents and others who deal with
homeschoolers so i think it would do
that when it comes to
standardized tests i just want to
address a question that was asked
earlier once when students take the
national tests they are sort of being
assessed against new hampshire standards
in as much as new hampshire has adopted
state standards because these nationally
norm standardized tests do you know test
for those standards so i think that was
a good question
um i support all the other testimony
regarding getting rid of them and i just
by way of comparison give you a few
other states that do require tests by
the way most states do not most states
do not require homeschoolers to do
assessments or to submit assessments
okay made that change back in 2012
representative hull was actually the
person who did that thank you jr
but in colorado they set it at 13th
percentile you have just about running
out of time so and i'm wrapping up
ohio's 25th percentile west virginia
just made the change from 40th down to
23rd percentile
um we've long supported the removal of
rulemaking authority from the commission
of education you have a very good law
it's very clear the commissioner does
not need to make rules which is a
tiresome cumbersome process so i would
encourage you to take the opportunity to
get rid of the rulemaking process which
i believe is included in the amendment
that representative leon has
produced and i want to thank you for
your kind attention
thank you very much thank you
that your mother that spoke earlier or
yes it is
i'll be quick and brief for the sake of
time hello my name is alyssa and i've
been homeschooled all my life in new
hampshire i don't believe that
homeschoolers should be held to a higher
standard than other students
and there should be special protections
for those with educational differences
and also not with different diagnosis
but also for instance what if one
student has english skills that surpass
their age level but that they struggle
with mathematics it would be extremely
beneficial to that student to have
advanced education in the english that
they desire
in addition to getting the extra help
they need in mathematics this would
allow them to grow to their full
academic potential
it would also be extremely helpful to
have equal access to
the public schools to be able to borrow
instruments and other useful materials
this would highly enrich my education
for instance i have wanted to borrow
musical instruments before from my local
public school but have been denied
homeschooling has been a great blessing
for me to explore and expand on my
various gifts and abilities while also
strengthening my academic difficulties
please pass hb 1663 to continue to allow
homeschoolers to have the best education
tailored to their individual needs and
interests and difficulties thank you for
your time and consideration
well done alyssa and thank you for
coming today really appreciate it
are there any questions for alyssa
you're off the hook
well i thank everybody for coming today
we went through all the pink cards now
and
i think your message has been
communicated so everybody have a
yes we're closing that hearing and we're
actions
oh
uh
um
is
let's see
uh
okay
yes
um
okay
oh
one
initially
um
foreign
oh
yeah
me
oh
okay
is
um
okay
1588.
right
stop
foreign
okay
yes
oh
we'd like to go ahead and start this
afternoon's uh hearings we have three of
them scheduled the first one on the
docket is
hp 1398. i want to apologize we've had a
schedule in the hallway we've had a
schedule in the calendar and it's been
off by
45 minutes or so and it's a result of a
whole lot of issues where things been
bumped around and i do apologize
hb 1398 is uh an act establishing a
committee to study the feasibility of
centralized criminal history records
checks in education i'd like to welcome
carol mcguire the prime sponsor of the
bill
thank you mr chair
i'm carol mcguire representing merrimack
district 29 which is allenstown epsom in
pittsfield
this bill started as a constituent
question she runs a business supplying
occupational therapists to the schools
mostly for special ed students
and they support a good number of
schools because
around here there's plenty of them with
an easy commuting distance
and she asked me why they had to get a
separate criminal records check for
every school
and i said that seems bizarre and i went
and looked into it
it turned out it's a combination of
different laws and rules that causes the
trouble
the
education statutes require everybody who
works in the school to have a criminal
records check
and it says that once such a check is
delivered to the school
it is reviewed
the
decision to hire or not is made and then
the records the data is destroyed
for privacy reasons
the department of safety which conducts
our criminal records checks
can only release them to government
entities without specific
authorization at least that's what i was
told
and so
it ends up that if you want to
work in the morning at
deerfield elementary school and in the
afternoon and the epsom school which are
like five or ten miles apart you need to
have a separate criminal records check
for each school
and if tomorrow you're going on to
pembroke there's a third one
this struck me
as extremely inefficient
and the more i looked into it the more
snarled it looked
and so i decided that this is one of the
few cases where a committee is
appropriate because the information and
the contacts and the understanding of
the issues
is not in one committee i mean i've got
a bill in my committee that might have
been a study committee but we're going
to interrupt study it because we have
all the in
the skills and the contacts we need this
one needs somebody with an education
background and somebody who knows
something about licensing and something
about criminal records checks
so that's those are the people that i
asked to be on the committee
the first thing is that i don't know
which other professions
are working in the schools and
likely to work in more than one school
i mean your basic teacher doesn't they
they work in one school
but
the professionals who support special ed
services
may not be needed full-time in a small
school
so they will work in more than one and
around here that's easy enough because
there's you know plenty of schools to
so we would need to want to find out
who's who's affected how often they move
how many schools they work on
and what other what else we could do
other than a
department of safety fbi records check
because there are some professions i
believe or at least i was told by by the
department of education
that the professional organization
certifies these people are okay to work
in schools
i'm not sure if that's true in new
hampshire or it's only in in
massachusetts or wherever they were
talking about but it's an idea
you know if you you could have a
uh
the professional organization of speech
language pathologists that you know
anybody who had the license is blessed
and certified and has passed
has no criminal record and is safe to
work in schools
it's an option i don't know that for
sure
i do know that the department of
education set this up for school drivers
and transport
operators because they
also work
for other more than one school
and it was a royal hassle for them
and so the department of education
started running the
collecting the background check data and
saying you know these
bus drivers and transportation monitors
are good are good to go to any school
and so that's
i'll answer whatever questions i can
thank you very much representative
mcguire are there any questions from the
committee
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative mcguire so this morning i
introduced a bill that would require
education service providers who are
receiving efa accounts and others
receiving public money to have
background checks would you would those
people be able to utilize this you think
if you
um it went through that's why we have to
study it representative porter i do know
that
the background check procedure
is being used much more intensely these
days than it used to be
and it is frequently a bottleneck for
other professionals
and if a somebody needs to get five
background checks
to go around to the local schools
that's
four other people that couldn't get a
clearance
further questions of carol mcguire
representative litchfield
thank you
would you believe we were just
discussing this literally a few days ago
to school board meeting
where we have an issue with subs we
could use a centralized location for
substitutes because we have a shortage
and boy this would really simplify
things yes
i'm sure i don't i'm not involved with
schools very much so i don't know which
professions you would need need or want
to have a centralized
database on but i'm sure that it could
be very useful
further questions
representative yes representative waltz
thank you so
i'm trying to remember and we've heard a
lot of bills but my recollection is
we've had testimony that the department
of education is starting a centralized
database for things like school bus
drivers and some other support people is
there any reason they can't do this for
teachers and subs and
uh we have to authorize them too or tell
them to
so could we instead of studying this
it appears that we sorry follow-up
that's fine instead of instead of
studying this wouldn't it make more
sense just to amend this bill to tell
them to do that and have a centralized
base for everybody so that we can have
all background checks and everybody has
access to it if you know all the pr all
the peop professions that need to be
included in that
instruction go i'd love to i would
certainly support it but i don't know
who who's working in the schools other
than
further further questions
we do have the department here so we can
get some technical advice there we've
been seeking it from our
our governor back there
well we'll
we'll elevate you then the full kernel
so at this point there's no more
questions we'll
move on to the next person which we have
uh here and we're going to get
[Music]
let's get uh our new hampshire state
police up here uh victor
is it m-u-z-z-e-y yes sir muzzy welcome
thank you chairman and thank you members
of the committee my name is victor muzzy
i am a lieutenant at the state police in
charge of record information services
which includes the
criminal records unit i'm here
this afternoon to just offer a couple of
points i suppose first of all i think
the department of safety would be in
support
of this bill to form a committee
to study these items which i think we
would agree any any way to alleviate
backlog and make things more efficient
of course we would be in support of that
really our only concern
would be is
i suppose making sure the committee is
aware of
a lot of the requirements that we we
would fall under for things like
disseminating background checks and how
those go to different places and
is at the hands of the fbi and
controlled by them so
as we saw with the bus drivers and bus
monitors
we had a little issue there where we had
to reach out for the fbi's say so even
though a law was enacted by the state
um dissemination of that was was really
up to them because it contained sigis
information so
that's really i think our only concern
is making sure that the study
understands or the committee i'm sorry
the committee understands
in researching what need be done to
determine how we can disseminate these
things that a lot of this is at the say
so of the fbi
and furthermore the other point that i
will make here is
line number
20 talks about the availability of other
background clearance procedures
and i don't know exactly what the
language and that may refer to but
if it's in reference to potentially
doing third party background checks or
things like that
certainly that's that's not a decision
for the department of safety to make but
just to make members of this committee
or the committee formed as a result of
the bill aware of what you would be
getting in regards to that check versus
what you wouldn't be getting just as an
educational piece so
i guess that's really what i can offer
you in the way of testimony we support
the idea of it and certainly the
efficiency of i think the intent of the
bill it's just a function of the
logistics of
carrying out whatever the committee
determines and that has a making sure
they have a full understanding
of the confines of which we may have to
operate under
okay happy to take any and all questions
thank you very much lieutenant um
are there any questions here
yes represent woodcock thank you
chairman
i'll try again thank you representative
thank you sir um i have two questions
the first one is
is there anything that that um in your
mind that would
having dealt with all these
certifications and checks uh that would
prohibit uh or require or why does it
require schools
using the same certified person to
require multiple checks for example
school i'm a i'm a coaching school a a
teacher in school b and i
i you know wash windows there on a
sunday school city i still have to have
a
from all three although i'm a certified
cleared one
yeah and i don't have a real good answer
for that that maybe somebody in the room
better suited to answer that question
for me
or for you
i guess it's a function of who's vetting
the candidate and i think as it stands
now that's on
a district level for some things and
certainly the school administrative unit
for others so i think it's a function of
maybe aligning those two things to allow
for that flexibility
but as it's written my understanding is
that authority to vet a candidate for a
particular position or role in the
school comes from
that building administrator or or um
person responsible for that that
facility
hey follow up yes go ahead thank you
chairman um so
based on what you just said on the who's
vetting it
if they're all vetting for
professional functions within the school
uh athletic department through the
department science department at three
different schools um so they're all
vetting for a school district with the
background check that your organization
does is the same background check
because they're all school district
or will be so many different regions
well the process is exactly the same
it's just a function of when the check
is done
so for example you could have somebody
that's got a clean record today but
tomorrow they commit a crime or get
convicted of a crime and then you know
you've got however much time passes so
the record would be updated and
refreshed
um
so the process is exactly the same for
all of those
units if you will okay but it's just a
function of again it's what it is today
may not be what it will be tomorrow
okay thank you mr
thank you sir further questions
yes representative nelson thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
what do they review
checks on teachers or someone doing
something like this so if i'm a teacher
you run the background
check i'm all set but do you go over
like every year to check it out to make
sure i haven't done anything bad in
between we do the state the department
of safety doesn't do that we provide
simply provide the record pursuant to
statute and rule to
whomever that
body may be the school administrative
unit so
we're just the keeper of the record and
other
questions
over there oh representative porter yeah
but i i might know the answer already so
i'll be brief so the records that you
send out to the school districts are
detailed records yes ma'am they're not
just superficial correct okay if you
were to send those to say the department
of education
and they looked them over could
they only send a
cast or failed to
somebody or would they be required do
you think to send the whole
record
from our standpoint it just depends on
the law it depends on the fbi it depends
on the law um that that's
we're happy to do either i suppose it's
just from our standpoint
how the record gets disseminated um is
of concern you know what i mean because
we we are at the mercy of the fbi to say
yes that's okay or no that isn't okay or
it can only be disseminated once versus
i disseminate it to you you disseminate
it further disseminated that further
dissemination is kind of where the issue
lies
or the concern not it's not an issue of
mine or ours it's just a function of can
we do it
further questions represent like us
yeah i do have i can't see you yes
i do have a question based on a
conversation we had earlier on an
earlier bill
and i i know
you've talked to us numerous times and i
currently we have this
education freedom accounts and a
scholarship organization is the one who
runs it and vets the vendors and etc
but
only government agencies can
request and get this information so the
question is
where we're using them to run our
government program
who are you using i guess
it's a scholarship organization
that is it that runs the program and
they're getting a record from the
department of safety the question can
they get a record from the department of
safety because we're asking them to vet
all of the people that work with the
kids
can they do that
i don't have an answer to that i would
say the fbi i think restricts it to
governmental agencies so
i i don't know i have to
look further thank you answer your
question
are there further
further questions
not seen thank you very much can you
hang loose though until we're finished
there it could be possibly if something
else yes i'd like to have uh attorney
fenton come up from the department of
education now
and
we've talked about this topic quite a
bit here and
um but now we have you know this issue
diana
could this be resolved without a
committee just through our
uh
doing something as representative waltz
has mentioned just trying to get on it
what are your feelings about that
uh well thank you for the record my name
is diana fenton i'm an attorney with the
i am very thankful to representative
mcguire for bringing the bill forward as
it is
she and i had the opportunity to speak
the overarching concern i suppose is
that
we want to be mindful of creating and i
mentioned this earlier today the
infrastructure by which the department
takes on this role the department is
fully capable and able to take on this
role and and we have done so with the
implementation of bus drivers and
first-time teacher educators
however i will just reiterate
that
uh
i think we just have to be mindful
of allowing the department the time to
get this up and moving and work out all
the kinks my hesitation is simply this
if we move too far too fast
children are harmed
period
and no one in this room is okay with
that
is it something the department can take
on absolutely it is a role that we are
willing and able to take in fact i will
share with you that when commissioner
edelblut first started and i shared with
him my vision for the department running
teacher applicant records
commissioner said to me well yeah let's
do that let's get it done tomorrow and i
said well let's
just slow it down a little bit um
and so we have worked quite extensively
to create this program legislatively we
have worked tirelessly with the
department of safety because as you've
heard from that testimony those federal
regulations are are
complicated to put it mildly
so it was in discussing this with
representative mcguire i said to her is
this something the department can do yes
absolutely it is a function they could
serve
but
when we start looking at this issue it
is a pandora's box it is a slippery
slope and you're going to quickly
recognize and i think representative
tanner you had the opportunity to to dip
your toe in this pool a little bit and
you were wise smarter than me and you
pulled it right back out um
it becomes a pandora's box because one
group says well i go from school to
school to school and another group says
yeah i do too
and so all of a sudden we have a bit of
a quagmire on our hands and i think we
have to be very mindful
of the role the department plays and
i think it would behoove us
to have a study committee
i know sometimes it feels like we're
kicking the can down the road but i
think in this particular instance
it would best be served to have those
thoughtful conversations not only with
the department of education but with our
partners at the department of safety to
really look at what this looks like and
how it will play out
because a couple of things that the
lieutenant mentioned
is that having stale records
and we also have to recognize that
when we look at the statute 189 13a
which is always our guiding principle in
this particular area
those set out a limited number of
offenses which prohibit
employment absolutely prohibit it and
that is clear across the state but each
district is given discretion to say i
can decide for my district for the
particular um position in front of me if
that record is going to work so they
have a lot of discretion so we have to
think very carefully about the role the
department would play and whether we
want to take that discretionary ability
away from the districts and it's a it's
a balancing test
so
i think it is a very complex topic when
you when you start peeling back the
layers and i know representative tanner
would agree with me although i i rarely
speak on behalf of people um
and so for those reasons
uh i i would suggest that we uh that
this committee established a study
committee i think representative
mcguire's
approach is appropriate
given the complexities
thank you very much i i agree with you
on that as a past administrator i know
that the district over here the
superintendent will receive something
i would receive something and both were
dealt with differently
and so we have those lower levels of
those agencies
you know reacting differently towards
certain situations so
this is a difficult topic to uh bridge
um it's a great topic to talk about yeah
but let's the bridge yeah well let's
take the opportunity to look at the
infrastructure we create with first-time
educator applicants those rules are just
going into place uh next week at our
next board meeting and so we need to
start
issuing those and and running those
records and reviewing those records as a
department and
see
it's inevitable anytime you take on a
new task that there will be bumps in the
road and we are aware of that and we're
willing to work through those but i
would like to work through those in a
smaller
chunk
and work out those issues than in a
bigger heavier lift again
because at the end of the day
if there is a misstep
it's child safety
and i told the commissioner when he
started in 2016 i'm not okay with that
and i stand before you with the same
testimony today
further questions yes representative
cornell thank you thank you for taking
my question you mentioned stale
records and i think this goes back to
representative nelson's question once
somebody goes through the check and
they're okay
do they get checked on a regular basis
or is is that it unless something's like
in the newspaper right thank you for the
question and the minute i said the words
i remember i recognized that i was
speaking in code and and people probably
thought i was talking about bread so i
apologize for that so um in the criminal
justice system if the minute a record is
a day old it's referred to as stale
because it's kind of like buying a new
car the minute you drive it off the lot
the price goes down the minute a record
is a day old we don't know anymore so um
currently in terms of employment
if i work at a district and i was
fingerprinted
when i started back in pick a year
i do not have to redo that background
check if i stay at that district
i will only have to redo that background
check if i go to another district again
it's an issue of employment
and that's when those
that comes up
so yes we have educators in the state
who have been employed at a district for
20 30 years and they've been subject to
representative maguire you have your
hand up here let's make her the the bill
come on up and sit yes thank you i
don't know about education but many of
the professions have a requirement to
renew one's license
that you report on any
criminal history that has happened since
you last got your license
so that if a speech-language pathologist
is licensed for two years
every two years they will report to the
board that they have not committed any
crime that would invalidate
their qualifications for working in
schools
i don't know
about
you don't have to put your hand up here
thank you
um so thank you representative mcguire
um
under the code of conduct if a teacher
is arrested for
a section five violation they have an
obligation to report that arrest
um it is not for
any and all arrests
so for example a dwi which is not a
section 5 violation would not have to be
reported to the department um
presumably the district would find out
about it one way or another but that
might be an issue of employment i would
imagine that most districts have an
employment policy that would require
that someone
report if they have been arrested but
that is going to be a district to
topic that representative mcguire
brought up that i would be remiss if i
didn't address
is the idea that a lot of professions
that are going into various school
districts such as speech language
pathologists
nurses things like that we have to be
cognizant that they have already gone
through some type of background check
for their license lawyers we go through
a background check you know and so we
can look at those entities very
carefully to make sure that we're not
being redundant in our practices and
also to make sure that nothing's falling
through the cracks
so when we look at schools and i mention
this to representative litchfield in the
hallway schools were designed and
envisioned to be open welcoming places
they were and it's wonderful and now
we're recognizing some of the pitfalls
of that policy and so we're trying to
tighten something that was designed to
be open and welcoming and so we have to
do it in a very thoughtful conscientious
manner
as we recognize the number of people in
the different types of people who go
through the schools the school doors
are there any further questions of the
department
last one from myself we've talked uh
about several bills dealing with
criminal background checks
if we form a committee here would it be
wise to fold some of those other issues
into this study or should this remain
at the end of the day
that is that is a decision for this
committee to make however i will say
this because that's a really that's a
really dirty lawyer answer isn't it yeah
yeah
is this being recorded i'm going to get
our own lawyer on top
i know i know i'm i'm hoping you don't
yes it is a great idea to look at all
these issues my hesitation is my answer
is simply this
i had a wonderful opportunity to work
with representative tanner on a similar
study committee and what we found was it
was overly broad
and again i don't want to speak on
behalf of representative tanner but my
experience my takeaway from that was i
think we would have
been better served if we had narrowly
tailored it to one or two issues the
minute we started talking about this it
was so big and it was so broad that
we really kind of stumbled on over our
own feet if that's fair to say um
and so
yes i think there is an opportunity to
talk about this in a broader picture my
only caveat and word of warning is
once you get started down this path
you're going to find that the ops the
octopus has a lot of arms
so
do with that what you will
and no one
now no one wants to chair that committee
i can tell everyone is going not me not
me um so yes i think it's a great
opportunity but it would only be
successful if the department of
education is there and the department of
safety
well we've already had representative
mcguire say she will chair it
perfect
yeah i agree
okay are there any other questions for
uh
the department not seniors thank you
very much thank you for the opportunity
do we have any other cards or is that
no yes that's it
can you get a card done if you haven't
for the record my name is russian
chester i live in bedford new hampshire
i'm not speaking to this bill uh either
opposed or support i'm just bringing up
a little bit of education and
understanding as to
what something like this
um i think so initially i came in
thinking that i was opposed to this
because that means spending money
um but after hearing the um
the representative who uh sponsored this
bill the prime sponsor for this bill i
think that it is really important to to
think about
looking into this and diving into this a
little bit closer
would you believe that
more than
seven of the
people that have come into my children's
school
to do story hour or to volunteer
have a criminal record history that i
would be extremely worried about them
being in my classroom
that's it thank you very much
questions
thank you thank you
so not having any other pink cards up
here we're going to close this hearing
and thank those who came thank you to
the department for showing up and
offering your input
and also to the other department the
education department
okay
okay the next bill we have is 1198.
this bill is relative to rules of the
department of education concerning
culture and climate
see we're supposed to start this at 2
yeah
that's like
watching
we're all over the road yeah so
uh representative um you're here with as
the prime sponsor of the bill
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of the committee um my name is
greg huff i represent belknap county
uh laconia
um
and you know if it has any bearing at
all i was a classroom teacher once
the purpose of this bell
is
there's a couple of
um
pieces of this and i'll try and be brief
and i only plan to talk for about five
minutes if that so please hold me to it
because i can get off on a tangent i'm
sure you folks don't want to hear any of
what this build does
is
all of our agencies have the ability to
create administrative rules
and these administrative rules
have the effect of law basically they
are
when perusing through the
in
i mean uh administrative rules
it's in uh
pretty much chapter uh 300 it goes
chapter 200 but but 300
has
many different
pieces of it 302 is duties of school
superintendents
300 by the way is titled the ministry
administration of minimum standards
for public schools and then it goes on
it outlines things of like school boards
principles duties um things
construction of schools
uh development of appropriate
appropriate daily activities but there
was one section in here
and it's in 306 that said minimum
standards for uh public school approval
and when i got into that
um
what grabbed my attention is is the
typically as a as an educator i learned
pretty quick
that um
there's a language that's spoken amongst
those who are in the education field
um i used to call it eduese i don't know
if it's still called that anymore it's
basically a way to put word salad a word
salad together with a lot of very very
good words that basically don't amount
to much
and that's what this climate culture
thing is in this particular section of
the administrative rules there's two
parts one part deals with um what the
school board
is required to do
um or or shall reflect in their uh
policies one is uh acknowledgement of
diversity and respect for differences
i'm going to start start
first off if you go to the beginning of
all of these administrative rules they
have definitions there are no
definitions for diversity um at all in
this or or
or what differences are
i know what the intent is and the intent
here is to go on the same four things
that are always the the diversity uh
argument um generally uh race
uh
but diversity is far far more than that
diversity could be intelligence
diversity can be
shoe size diversity could be uh the
proclivity to like a particular color or
an athletic ability there's zillions
literally countless ways to be diverse
my point is
is that
this is hamstringing
your educators
because they have to follow this stuff
okay there's a a few other things in
here too that are are similar um i'll
give you one of my favorite ones here uh
uh where is it a respectful use of
language and behavior by all school
members that is void of ethnic racial
and sexual stereotypes and biases
sounds great
our schools are failing miserably when
it comes to education i think
climate and culture is not something
that actually needs to be in
in this type of a uh
rule
these your schools are more than capable
on that particular one respectful use of
language i'm pretty sure
all school teachers
demand respectful use of language this
is not something that needs to be in
here
it's it's an overreach and the overage
comes from a
from a system where by
us the legislative body has abdicated
their
authority in creating rule of law
we've done so by giving administrations
the ability to create what they want
most of the time they do a pretty good
job sometimes they don't and all of the
time they're not accountable to the
people of the state
so
in this instance
the only way that i could go after this
is i can't or we can't do anything about
what the administrative rules are that
they
decide are going to be it either has to
run out because they go i believe in
blocks of eight years
net currently um
they either run out and are not re-upped
or they're rewritten at that point or
they just can or they can be continued
um
unless we
dial back
what it is that they can do
which is what my bill does that's why
there's really no mention of
of
the actual statute that's um in the
education thing that's a 306.06 if you
want to actually
that's mentioned in my bill of
um school board state board of education
the powers that they have that's under
uh title uh
i believe it's 15 education chapter 186.
this particular one is 186.5 and i just
want to quickly just go over a
particular little piece of it it's a
small
section and i won't bore you with the
whole thing but it says
it it may make all rules and regulations
necessary for the management of its own
business and conduct
and for the conduct of its officers
employees and agents to ensure the
efficient administration of public
schools and the administration
of the work of americanization
in teaching english to non-english
speaking adults and in furnishing
instruction in the privileges duties and
responsibilities of citizenship which is
hereby declared to be an essential part
of
public school education
climate and culture
i ask anybody here to define that
specifically and what that has to do
with teaching children how to read write
think properly any of this any of this
stuff
um so that's basically it in a nutshell
i'd be more than happy to entertain any
questions any you may have of me uh and
i'll do my best to answer them
thank you very much uh questions
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair did you do
any research before writing this bill
a little bit yes uh follow up on that
yes did you um did you research um the
expiration of administrative rules yes
they generally expire about every eight
years i believe currently and um and
then the final thing is
where did you research and come to the
conclusion
that quote fail schools are failing
miserably when it comes to education um
that one pretty much comes from my
hometown where the um
actual
uh proficiency rate is i believe 32
so 32 proficiency rate of children that
are actually on
grade level with reading writing
and mathematics which means 66 percent
are failing
so follow-up would it be fair to say
then
that when you're talking about schools
are failing miserably when it comes to
education you're talking about the
schools in the town you are from and not
a statewide phenomena no no i'm talking
yeah that's just
when i to to clarify when i say failing
miserably i'm saying that academically
and achievement wise they're not where
they should be
and things of this nature which are
absolutely useless are involved in
hampering our educators from doing what
it is that they are supposed to be doing
i hope that answers your question
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
did you talk to anybody at the bureau of
student wellness at the department of
education i did not i did not um i think
you might want to because they do
they've done a significant amount of
work around climate and culture through
the department of education
and i think that um
they might be able to clear up some of
the
questions that you have about the
usefulness and appropriateness of
looking at the climate and culture of a
school building
because
i i think there may be more than one way
to define climate and culture and i
think that
you may only be looking at it from one
uh
so the question
my question is have you spoken to
anybody at the bureau of student
wellness i haven't and as far as um
climate and culture goes
you're absolutely right it can mean many
many different things
the part that i have a problem with is
is the culture is american
we're all american we all live in this
country that's our culture there
shouldn't be a subculture being taught
in the schools
and that's what i'm trying to address
here
could a climate of honesty and a culture
of learning
be a climate and culture that we might
want to have in our schools
absolutely um
you have to understand how
how this had how i had to have this
written
i can't specifically pull out pieces of
the administrative rule
the only way that that can be done
is by this broader
stroke of the brush i would much rather
just have some of the because to be
honest with you there are in that small
little piece of the of the
administrative rule only about half of
it do i actually have a a problem with
the other half is is inconsequential or
fine
um
but after going over and over and over
my options to be able to take things out
okay
the language was terrible
in in other words um if i can just give
you a quick example um let me just
quickly find this here if i can
okay
if i wanted to have
the acknowledgement of diversity and
respect for differences taken out and
and and don't get me wrong that's fine i
just don't think it should be a priority
to be taught we're all different it's a
given everybody in this room is
different it's not something that needs
to be dwelled on or or harped on
the the point is is
if it was to be written to take that out
it would sound something to this nature
it is not um applicable for a school to
be able to adopt a policy that is
favorable to diversity and
you see what i mean yeah it was that's
the face i made i'm like
there's just no way that you can write
something like that it just it sounded
absolutely horrible and it it didn't
really meet
the purpose of what i was trying to
accomplish here i hope that answers you
i have a question for you i'm looking at
the minimum standards of public school
approval right now
underneath 306.06 culture and climate
yes and one of the statements in there
says the school administration shall
provide professional development
opportunities
great directed at understanding the
policies and reporting requirements that
support a safe and healthy school
environment
that's under the section that you're
talking about
there's other sections uh
review ways in which equity gaps and
achievement which we're constantly on
this committee dealing how we close
those gaps
that we have on our statewide assessment
and can be reduced and barriers to
learning can be eliminated
as i read the statements whether it's an
a b or c underneath what you're calling
the culture and climate here and which
is identified as culture and climate
i guess i need some help here in
understanding why these policies that
shall be adopted by the local school
board or school administration and staff
or school administration
are are contrary to what we should be
doing in schools
there's a lot there i'll try to i'll i
may have to ask you to repeat but i'll
i'll try to answer you in in in the
order that you asked
um the school administration shall uh
provide uh development
that was one of the ones that i had
mentioned earlier that was fine as far
as i was concerned the thing also that
you uh if you do peruse through all of
this
literally almost everything that is in
this particular piece is covered
somewhere else in all of the education
uh they cover health they cover
well-being they cover personal
development they cover all of these
things this is a redundancy basically
as far as uh work together and a fair
and equitable uh was it was it
uh
which one was a code of conduct code of
discipline is that the one that you
mentioned i i read one uh a review of
equity gaps and achievement yeah
administration and staff i'm going to
say something that's not popular
everybody's different
if somebody is smarter they're smarter
if somebody is not quite as smart that
happens you can you obviously you're
going to try and educate everybody as
best as you can
but equity is not
the opportunity equity is the outcome if
you're trying to make everybody have an
equal outcome that means those who are
very very high achieving are going to
have to be pulled in and those who are
very low achieving are going to have to
be brought up
otherwise leveling everybody's ability
and i think one of the things that i
remember when i was a teacher was we
don't teach to what is fair for
everybody we teach to what everybody
needs
so in this particular instance i would
take uh
issue with that entire thing is it does
not go to the actual uh support of
people learning it goes to the support
of people learning all at the same level
further questions represent woodcock
thank you chairman
good afternoon thank you for taking my
question thank you as i'm reading the
the bold section of bull did i guess
section of the proposed uh bill change
yes
i'm taking back when i get to the part
that says any rule requiring school to
adopt the policy concerning
culture and climate could you talk about
prior to that shall not adopt uh would
would you
so i may have some leniency or some
latitude here rather than lead would you
say that
i don't know what would be included in
that i i think i know where you're going
on the idea of you want to protect the
the children you know i just want to
know if you think climate bullying's in
climate i i wouldn't i would so bullying
is not there
was it would discrimination be there
i don't hypothetically no it's not there
in there so discrimination
and bullying those are not in climate
items in the school
i don't see them in there no
okay would they be in the culture of the
school
um i don't know that they would be in
the culture of the school i'm not really
sure where you're where you're going
with this well what i'm trying to
discern is things like bullying and
discrimination
we seem to be
uh in the culture of a school you are
prohibiting school boys from adopting
any policy concerning them no i'm not
there shall not a doctor enforce any
rule requiring schools
to adopt the policy concerning cultural
climate so i'm asking you correct what's
in there correct culture and climate in
here none of which you what you asked me
of is in here all of which you asked me
of are currently illegal already so it's
not a question it's somewhere else like
i said this is redundant
so my point is was
if you have a school board policies
that deal with discrimination or the
ability not to discriminate
or if you have
school board policy to deal with
bullying or
rules and procedures in school not the
bully
because they all impact the climate and
culture of that schoolhouse
your bill as i see it says that those
those should not be there i see i see
where you're going okay
um that's not the intent of what i'm
doing here
obviously i i don't want to
i don't want this to
uh hamstring stop or
curtail
any particular school or school board
from doing what they
deem appropriate for their children in
their
area so that's not the intent of this
i don't i don't believe
adopting those policies or
agreeing on those policies
this is supposed to mean that the
department of education will not require
it or enforce it if it is not there
thank you sir um well i guess my point
is that's not what it says uh and i
think you'd be hard-pressed to go into
any school
in this state and talk to any teacher
administrator and ask them if they
believe that bullying and discrimination
are not part and parcel of the culture
of that school and that there needs to
be school board policies that are
enforceable to create a better culture
and climate in that school
again
bullying is illegal and it's in every
handbook pretty much of every school
that you can't so i
i i i understand what you're saying and
i don't want the restriction if if
if that is the opinion eventually of
this committee
i'd be more than happy to
have the wording changed so that it
doesn't do what you're describing
okay
thank you thank you
thank you welcome further further
not seeing thank you yes right
representative moffitt
thank you miss sheriff i'm trying to
understand the intent here and tell me
if if this is
if i'm understanding it in this way
let me put it this way you don't want to
see the state board or doe
favor
what you don't want to see happen is the
state board or doe uh
promoting or supporting
values or approaches that
don't have community consensus support
does that
yes and and i'll explain it uh
in a hypothetical
okay
the the climate and culture section here
is is
seems to be a redundancy and a catch-all
and and the reason it makes me
uncomfortable is because it has been
adopted by a bureaucracy
that bureaucracy theoretically can
change
tomorrow climate and culture
could be
everybody has to wear a mask
tomorrow's climate and culture could be
do you see one it's just an arbitrary
thing that was put in here
it didn't get it there was no hearing
like this to discuss the merits of it
when you go into gel car and this is my
understanding i'm learning these things
for for this but from my understanding
is is gel card doesn't really do
anything as far as what the rule is they
just want to make sure that it is proper
and crosses the eyes and dots the t's
they don't have the ability to say no
this is bad we're taking it out or this
is good or we should amend
so
to work on this
this was the only avenue that i had
yes thank you thank you
further questions
maxine thank you very much thank you uh
mr chairman and thank you honourable
good afternoon chairman ladd and members
of the education committee
my name is holly stevens i'm the
director of public policy for nami new
hampshire
the national alliance on mental illness
nami new hampshire is a non-profit
grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
and on behalf of nami new hampshire i'm
here today to speak in opposition to
house bill
1198 relative to rules of the department
of education
concerning culture and climate in
schools
so i know there's been a little bit of
discussion about what climate and
the governor had put together a task
force on school safety that came out
with a report
in 2018
and in that report um and it is
available
online and if anybody would like i'm
more than happy to send the link to it
um
a school's culture is the set of norms
that defines the behavior inside the
school and largely determines what is
considered socially acceptable behavior
between classmates
culture is significantly important
to the social emotional and academic
success
cult you know a positive culture in a
school if a school has a pro
positive culture
or a negative culture
um
it's a great predictor of dropout rates
absenteeism
truancy
suspension
drug use
violence
and positive school culture is closely
associated with pro-social motivation
academic motivation
self-esteem conflict resolution and
additionally
positive
school cultures have been linked to
as
representative woodpock alluded to
a reduced incidence of bullying
bullying in a school the the increased
amount of bullying in a school
is one of the main predictors of
and a 2010 study correlated a student's
perceived sense of security which is
also part of the culture and community
having a safe environment if students
felt safe
in their culture in the school there was
an 18
increase
in student score performance
so the culture and climate is directly
linked to academic performance as well
as social
and as you know mentioned about the
bullying um
not only is it associated with violence
but it's also associated with high
levels
there's no direct causal link so no
one's done a study that says yes
this child was bullied there was
suicidal behavior there's not a direct
but what they have found that
involvement in bullying if the child has
other risk factors it increases the
chances that the young person will
engage in suicide related behaviors and
i have provided
the citation for that study
currently in new hampshire suicide is
the second leading cause of death
for young people and young adults
so any action that new hampshire can
take
to reduce the incidences of suicide and
violence among young people is
incredibly important
our state has a vested
interest
in assisting the schools
and cultivating a positive safe culture
and climate
throughout each school system
house bill 1198 would prevent the
department of education
from doing this important work
and so for these reasons nami new
hampshire requested the committee
um vote inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1198 and i will take any
questions that the committee has thank
you very much are there any questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you you're welcome
uh next card which we have is
good afternoon members of the committee
thank you so much for having me
i'm here
my name is emma savini i represent new
futures i am the children's behavioral
health policy coordinator there
new futures is a non-partisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all granite staters
new futures opposes this bill because it
may erode the progress that our state
has made toward implementing the
multi-tiered system of support for
behavioral health and wellness commonly
referred to as mtssb
a critical part of our system of care
that creates a positive learning
environment for all students
mtssb is an
evidence-based comprehensive system of
social and behavioral and emotional
supports to promote student wellness and
improve engagement and learning it's a
three-tiered system at the bottom of the
kind of pyramid if you would imagine it
tier one
are interventions that a school can
implement to improve the social and
emotional wellness for all students
the second tier which represents fewer
students is interventions that the
school can implement
to improve the wellness and social
social wellness of students who need
more severe interventions and then at
the top of the tier tier three
are interventions that the school
implements for students who need
more intensive treatments and
interventions that that to improve their
social and emotional wellness
um the culture and climate school in of
schools and mtssb form almost a cycle in
creating a positive culture and climate
in schools a positive culture and
climate lends itself to proper and
better mtssb implementation and then
implementing mtssb then increases the
positivity
for culture and climate and a better
if passed
house bill 1198 could erode the progress
that we have made so far in implementing
mtssb
the rule cited by the bill sponsor
rule
306.06
is the minimum standard for culture and
climate that gives kind of the basis for
mtssb implementation
um eliminating this rule altogether
would redu
remove that minimum standard and
therefore schools
would be
likely less likely to
implement mtssb
schools provide students with much more
than just the in education in the
traditional sense like reading and math
schools are really important for
students to
get a foundation in social and
behavioral learning so that they can be
successful later on
the culture and climate in schools is
crucial to providing a safe and healthy
environment for students to learn how to
interact with
other peers and their
you know teachers and administrators
especially with covid where it's an
extremely tumultuous time programs like
mtssb give students a healthy way to
learn how to cope with large changes and
major stressors in their lives
by removing the minimum standard for a
culture and climate in schools
[Music]
this mtssb and other similar programs
will be
less likely to be implemented
and schools will no longer be the
safe place for students to foster social
emotional and behavioral learning that
they need to grow into successful adults
for those reasons new future strongly
urges the committee to vote house bill
1198 and expedient to legislate
thank you very much are there any
questions for new futures
yes representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question and thank you and
holly for reminding us that this came
out of the governor's
school safety task force and that's what
this is a result of well my question is
from what i understand and i may be
wrong the department of wellness works
with school districts across the state
to implement
mtssb or something similar
on how it fits into each particular
district so it could be a huge program
in one place
and a small program in another place
depending on what is decided on by the
community i'm pretty sure this community
input
into these plans and
it's not just something that's thrown in
i think it's
i think it's actually merrimack that
worked on it for five years before they
started implementing something and they
worked with the community they worked
with um the schools they worked with
businesses and then they implemented
what ship best into their school
district and i i think that's what
is going on in the state now little by
little they're working with areas so
taking this out of it would you know
undo a lot of the work that's been going
on in the state am i right
you are exactly thank you so much for
the steps are exactly as you as you
described the the community and the
school district determines that they're
going to take part in mtssb there's a
period of time where the school
determines what types of interventions
the school needs what can they improve
on their culture and climate and then
it's an ongoing process of refining and
ensuring that their interventions
they're putting in are working they
check data to make sure that the
interventions are working
and reaching those goals that they've
set
thank you and i'm sorry that the sponsor
didn't stay to hear all that
further questions
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members for
allowing me to speak on this i just want
to start by saying that although i'm a
bedford resident now
oftentimes when i'm speaking i'm
speaking for when my children are in
school
and they were not always in the bedford
school system so i just wanted to make
sure that i clarified that so i'm not
bashing my school district that i
currently live in however what i will
say is that i listen to what the um
representative or what um
the director for public policy with nami
had to say and with regards to what new
futures had to say and my concerns is
that what is happening in our school
system yes we have mtssb
and i think it's been hijacked
i think that what is happening now is
there's a culture and climate that's
going on in our school districts that
may be put in place by the school boards
and not necessarily by the community
standards that the constituents that
voted those people into office really
understand what's going on
for instance in bedford schools since we
well bedford school specifically but i
just checked a couple of other schools
districts too
would you believe that prior to adopting
an mtssb
the amount of suicides was much lower
than it is today
in the few school systems that i checked
would you also believe that in the
school systems that i checked and i'm
more than willing to provide you with
this information
like i said i was sitting back there and
spending a lot of time looking things up
would you also believe that
right now in bedford new hampshire there
is a program for students in our high
school
that
allows for kids to talk about
maltreatment
there has been a couple of um
canvassings done of those students
one out of five of those students that
have identified bullying
or
mis
uh
inappropriateness or anything to that
effect suicide ideation would you
believe that one in five
say they were not a victim
but they were basically bullied into
identifying themselves as victims
so that's the problem with
mtssb and that is what this
uh
bill is trying to combat
so i believe strongly that
discrimination is discrimination
culture and climate should never be it
that should not be something that we
have to talk about
discrimination is discrimination so the
bottom line is is if you have a history
of abuse and neglect and your child and
your other child does not have a history
of abuse and neglect they should not be
identified differently
and the more inclusive we try to become
the more diversive we are that's
happening to our government our our
children
thank you
questions for the presenter yes
representative cornell thank you could
you please tell me how you got people's
private information on how they reply to
the surveys
when you said one in five um
admitted that they were bullied into
giving the answer that they gave
how do you find that out so there's a
facebook group
there's a facebook mind thank you
well no it's just that the children have
said that
okay
thank you are there any other cards for
this uh particular bill
he might be trying to say something but
he's
saying the wrong way
you know i have a daughter
a granddaughter who
was chased out of the school and that's
why she went to saint j because she was
bullied that was the culture of that
athletic program she was in
you know if you're the top dog
go after the top dog
then when i was in alaska and kodiak
the high school there had a reputation
of having gangs in it
and fighting that was the culture of
that school
that was the climate of that school
so
we want to
put in place a climate which is contrary
to that
and do we do it to our board policies
i'm sorry i i think that was way off the
yeah good thank you very much
not everybody has a lieutenant colonel
but i don't know if you read these
things right here they're pretty broad
they're not dealing with
we got going on in schools right
um
thank you mr chair thank you uh members
of the committee for for hearing my uh
my introduction to this bill uh
i it seems like i can't go anywhere in
the town of derry without uh the subject
being brought up uh i bump into parents
and they're they're livid uh the the
kids aren't feeling well when they get
out of school uh you know they i had a
call from a a
a student he was in the eighth grade at
west running brook school
and uh
you know he said that uh he wears his
mask in school you know he's forced to
they're humiliated and stuff if they
don't and um
you know by the teachers by the way and
um
he uh he says you know by 10 o'clock or
so he's not feeling well
and uh you know
he's got a headache he's got you know uh
nausea stuff like that and uh you know
that's that's not a good uh good climate
to try to teach a kid and he gets home
from school and it takes him an hour for
the headache and the nausea to go away
um and like i said the bullying that
goes on uh you know almost encouraged by
teachers and stuff and and if you think
we don't have bullies for teachers in
this state
boy can i tell you some stories you know
um you know representative bowman and i
were just talking about it he he
experienced i experienced it with my
daughter uh as a matter of fact my my
niece um
she has a a niece through marriage
and
you know and it was because of because
of masks and mask mandates and stuff up
in wakefield but uh
her niece has biracial children
and and this teacher told this woman
that she should take her kids to another
school district because they don't have
any black kids in in wakefield it's
being investigated by the human rights
commission right now and
in the department of education um you
know we do have bullies for teachers
some of them i thought most of my
teachers are great but uh anyway um you
know that that's that's going on at west
running brook school um i've got a
i sent this around uh it's a letter an
email
from the uh the principal at west
running brook and he's uh more or less
saying that while you know the kids that
won't wear a mask we're going to
re-educate them we're going to have
re-education camps on friday friday
after school
okay those aren't his words but that's
what it says
uh and where about where have i seen
that before you know uh
you've also got a an email from dr
michael leon uh
and he's describing the the
the uh the
the uh the way
they there is there is no uh scientific
studies that say masked work okay
medical interventions are evaluated
based on two criteria safety and
efficiency
any clinical independent interventions
must be evaluated must be evaluated in
the context of both parameters
to date new hampshire has not been this
has not been the case in new hampshire
efficiency has has
been assumed in safety harm in
parentheses has not been given any
serious consideration the current bill
empowers parents not the teachers to con
consider both and make the best decision
for their children based on all current
current available data uh he goes on to
to say that you know there are no
scientific studies i was in i was
subbing in health and human services the
other day and
another doctor stood up and said the
same thing you know uh you know and as a
matter of fact he he asked the question
how many children without underlying
causes
you know from the uh 19
up to up to age 19 have died in new
hampshire because of covet
and the answer to that is zero
so why are we why are we forcing kids to
wear masks
you know and and and suffer through the
day be sick through the day and be
bullied in school
and uh you know this is nonsense uh
windham
just went mask optional two or three
days ago uh northwood did the same thing
ralph tells me litchfield did the same
thing mites my town will not they will
not back off it because it's been such a
contentious uh thing that the dug defeat
in the ground the heels in the sand and
uh you know will not will not do it
i hate to say the state has to do
something about it but they're
overstepping their bounds there is no
law
you know they're they have no right to
do this they can't tell a kid he has to
wear socks to school
never mind a mask
and um
you know it's time to stop it's time to
stop the bullying it's time to stop the
nonsense
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh you
indicated in your testimony that
i i guess this memo from the principal
about a fri the friday
friday class
was
like a re-education camp yeah and you
said we all know what that is related to
what what were you referring to i i said
we all know where we've we've read that
too yeah where did where where did you
back in the 40s there was there was this
guy called adolf hitler that used to do
that okay he had re-education camps
okay um you know here's here's another
another piece of nonsense this was
written on the on on the 19th very much
okay
further questions
represent mullen
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh you mentioned that this is a
contentious issue in derry
absolutely so um
would it be
assumed then that the school is trying
to deal with
people who are very upset about the
wearing of masks and people who are very
upset about the not wearing of masks
that would be correct but why is any one
group's fear any any any more legitimate
i don't have an answer for you for that
sir
woodcock thank you chairman
thank you representative for taking my
question um
looking at
the documents you gave us
and the westbrook running
brook middle school
i guess the copy of an email
where the front where the superintendent
uh principal apparently said
to be clear this time is designated for
design for students who have chronically
not responded to the encouragement
prompts and support from staff
is not intended for students whose mass
happens to slip below their nose
just 30 minutes on a friday afternoon
is it your thinking then that that
sounds like bullying
when children are getting sick and
they're told they have to do it anyway
yes it is bullying i'm just asking that
comment that you made
a testimony
like i just said if if children are
getting sick and he's going to have them
stay after school yes that's bullying
okay follow-up yes well that's only one
second question if the school has rules
where they happen to be
and the teachers are required to enforce
the rules are promulgated by the school
board
um do you feel that that's their job
the teachers do have to answer to the
school board but so maybe the school
board needs to be told what what they
have to do because um they're
they're going on on uh medical
medical uh it doesn't exist okay i'm not
questioning the validity of the policy
i'm questioning your statement that the
teachers were bullying for following the
rules that's what you said they were
bullying for following the rules of what
they do all i'm asking you if the school
has rules are the teachers supposed to
follow them or not
a teacher is not supposed to not
supposed to bully make fun of uh you
know and and that's what that according
to that student that called me that's
what they're doing did you find that on
facebook as well or no i got a telephone
call from that
is it is there a puddle or something
i won't i won't melt
okay
uh thank you for having me honorable
reps um
my name is david kylie i
live in atkinson new hampshire and
i have um
three children in public school one is
is currently at the um
timberlane regional school district and
i've been pretty vocal about mass with
my school board
essentially
at the first physical physically present
meeting that were we were able to have
that quickly got switched to zoom on
may 20th until the 91a rules were put
back in place i believe june 1st or 2nd
one of the things that you know that i'm
having trouble with you know i totally
agree there's there are there are a few
different studies that uh the cdc has
put up in pre-release until they were
taken down
relative to clusters and counties in
arizona they really made no sense the
authors admitted they were crude and
they never were actually released but
there's about 167 studies that show from
the brownstone um institute that show
that they don't work
you can debate that all you want none
versus 167 you know certainly there's
different variations of expertise that
people need to to look at my concern
really has to do with the um the
inability for our elected officials
within the school
board
as well as the you know appointed uh
bureaucratic uh
uh
appointed people like dr chan for
instance
who has some things that have been
contrary to um even statements made by
the cdc such as that you know without
mask we're gonna have major problems
with spread even after the barnstable um
study that was done in july where the
cdc came out and said you know look you
know these these uh we have spread it
it's gonna be equal no matter what you
do with vaccines so there's there's a
lot of information that's coming out
from experts that are in positions of
authority who are meeting with
superintendents um and they're telling
them one thing but they can't really
back it up and i can the only thing that
i can say is that from a parent's
standpoint when we're being told that we
have research and studies that show that
mass work to prevent the spread of
covert 19 and you ask them okay can you
please provide me with that research can
you show me what due diligence that you
performed to make it okay whereby like
in something as simple as article two in
our bill of rights in new hampshire you
know that says we have the right to
protect our property and pursue
happiness how can you violate that and
they turn around i said well you know
new hampshire dhhs actually has that
research you'll have to ask them so i'm
not shy when it comes to communicating
and calling
people in government i called his office
several times was never able to make
contact and i wrote an email and i asked
these very questions i've been told that
you guys have the research and i get no
response but i am told through
you know my in my own discovery is that
they're really relying on the cdc who
post these pima county and maricopa
county studies on clusters where you've
got a
county that has clusters that are 75
percent of the population in the entire
state of arizona and they're being
equally compared to a county that has
maybe uh five percent of the population
now these things don't make any sense um
so my issue uh my support of this bill
really comes from the fact that i still
have yet to be provided from an elected
official within my district from a
superintendent from you know anyone at
new hampshire dhhs which shows me that
these things actually stop the spread
the latest and greatest from cdc is they
put out a new study that says you know
cloth cloth masks are pretty much
useless or the least effective they say
and then they go into the
improperly worn surgical mass which as
we know you know from the side and the
space between the nose that's about nine
miles of distance compared to a ping
pong ball you know when you talk about
airborne particulates
you can go out and you can look at um
you know osha has has a lot of
information
there's plenty of industrial hygienists
that have unbelievable information or
references to studies the epa has plenty
of information out there you're never
going to find something where you can
prove that these mass work unless you're
talking about a respirator meaning an
n95
that has a filtration device on it and
that's if you can keep it clean because
if you can't keep it clean it's really
doing nothing so i think if we're going
to exchange our right you know to
have the ability to be
animal costumes in uh you know chokers
around their necks with leashes hanging
off but we can't let them smile
i think it's really difficult for me to
accept the fact that no
expert
can tell me why they're doing this and
when you when we have an environment
like hey governor says we have local
control when the local control says hey
we're only following the recommendations
of new hampshire dhhs
in new hampshire dhs hs can say not us
it's just a recommendation really the
parent is left in the middle everyone's
punting back and forth and we're the
monkey and i think it's a time it's time
for this to stop i think it's time for
us to really just
knock off the nonsense let these kids
smile let them breathe if you don't
think there's a restriction breathing
why are you wearing it because you're
not preventing anything from coming in
your lungs
in theory so
i i don't really know what else to say
other than we should be making it as
hard as possible to um you know allow
school districts to put these things on
require these things on the children's
faces in my opinion we should stop the
noble lying and you know be on with it
and move on you know that's that's it
thank you any questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
sir have you googled this to find the
studies
oh yes yes i uh i don't use google but
yes i have i've read the studies i just
googled it and the one of the very first
things that came up would you believe is
a study from stamford dated september
1st
that is peer-reviewed randomized study
on the use of masks with it's jointly
with stamford and yale medical schools
and law school and uh yeah both medical
schools um
with the randomized study with hundreds
of of people showing in in multiple
sites showing how the use of surgical
masks and other masks have helped limit
the transmission of covet the studies
are out there i believe and that's why i
asked if you google it would you believe
it i had no trouble finding a study just
sitting here while you were chatting
that
a professional study from some of the
top universities in the country that
immediately as i say one of the first
things that came up prove that it does
prevent transmission
i i would venture to say that uh using a
strong word like prove
it would be um inaccurate but i would
say that i don't google because you're
normally going to find
things that support masking up top
i tried maybe brave or i tried
duckduckgo where you're going to find a
more of a bigger population of studies
that come from universities as well like
brown or stanford
and i think that's that's probably fair
i haven't read the study that you're
talking about but i will say that you
know i've seen significant bias in
google and you can certainly look at dr
robert epstein's studies on google so
that you can get a better context of
what they're doing with their search
results you might want to try google
scholar that might be more to your
liking
thank you further questions represent
woodcock
thank you thank you thank you thank you
scott taking my question um i know at
the last speaker we seem to get off
track
um
more more for the jogging than the
intent of the bill
certainly
uh but beyond that back to the bill but
the bill the bill really doesn't handle
the
your concern of the school board's
policy i know it's kind of tough the
school board's policy of masking any
particular you may be talking himalayan
regional or whatever the district
happens to be that's not what the bill
says the bills
it does in general but the specifics of
the bill talks about if in fact a school
has a policy of masking
and you do not want your child to
participate in the policy of masking or
the parent choice then you would be
allowed to take your child out of that
school and place them in any public
private school uh and
it says didn't say in the state but for
sure it's in the state um at the cost
and transportation of the school because
for example you could take your
youngster out of your home school if you
didn't agree with the policy and send
him to say a proctor or brewster or
oprah academy or to a private school or
to
you know another public school
down the road from where you have to
live sure so that's the essence of the
your concern about the policy is
justified to the local school board
doing things you don't particularly care
for and how you remedy that um but the
bill talks about just moving a youngster
from one school to another
whether it be accepted by another
district or private school now do you
think that that that policy is sound
uh to answer your question i think it is
i think if you go back to article two
and you talk about the equality of
rights and if you have a school board
that is preventing you know your right
to uh express yourself through smile or
breathing or maybe even access to an
education however we want to define
rates it fits um i would say 100 percent
that you know not only do as you said i
started out by saying i think that this
um this this is a difficult thing for
parents to accept without due process
but i i also agree that the incentives
that are in this bill
make it possible to uh provide an equal
access to not having to wear a mask
for whatever reason you see fit
including you know your access to an
education so yes i do i think thank you
thank you
jeremy okay another question represent
cordelia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here i was just wondering if
your school in atkinson
has mandatory mass policy and if they uh
provide for
exemptions for instance medical
exemptions or even exemptions for
students with an iep or 504 plan
um i i i can't speak to that um i can
say that i'm aware that they
they re-implemented that
for this school year they didn't last
year which i think they admit was a
mistake the only thing i can tell you is
that i have friends that have kids who
that is not always being honored um even
doctors notes are not always being
honored unless they fit certain
you know definitions of disability with
respect to services being brought on by
the school
but i'm not an expert so i apologize i
can't really give
thank you very much i really appreciate
see i have this on and you can hear me
thank you good afternoon chairman lad
and members of the committee
deborah howes here from the american
federation of teachers new hampshire and
i appreciate this chance to address the
committee on hb 1588
i'm here to oppose this and
the main issue is
because
it is a matter of local control
we strongly feel that this would be the
state getting in the middle of a
decision that is really best left up to
a school districts local school boards
to all the parents and the voters in the
district
well this bill is written to give
individual parents the right to object
to having a student
wear a mask in school it has deeper
consequences because removing those
students to other educational options
which is the remedy suggested in this
bill
has a huge could have a huge cost
to the district and that has an impact
on the education that is offered to all
the rest of the students
that are in those public schools to all
their families who choose those public
schools and support them and to the
local voters and local property
taxpayers
i wish with all my heart that we weren't
still in this place in the pandemic
where we're having to talk about masks
and other mitigation measures so that we
can keep schools open
i would really like and all my
colleagues would really like to be able
to teach and see our students face to
face and see their whole face not just
this part of it
but we need to do what we can
so that we can keep schools open and in
person
and i understand how strongly people
feel on both sides of the mask issue
but having the state step in like this
will not make it any better
new hampshire has long tradition of
local control
and local democracy that gives parents
and educators a voice in schools and
communities through their local school
board this bill inserts the state into
safety decisions that should be left to
families and communities to work out
with their elected school boards
and as i was saying before the budgetary
impact on a district could be huge
because the remedy suggested is that a
parent who objected
to a locally adopted mask mandate
could send their student
to any other school public or non-public
or any program that was approved under
the
existing state voucher program
that could be a small cost that could be
a large cost depending upon what the
program is what the school is how far
away it is the transportation would also
have to be borne by the
sending district
that could very quickly add up to
needing to cut your budget
that
would very soon you know mean that
you're looking at cutting classes you're
looking at cutting staff
that is not fair to all the other
students all the other
families that are depending on that
so if we're talking about balancing
rights
you're balancing the rights of the
individuals who object versus the rights
of all the other students and families
relying on that public school
this new bill is an unfunded unlimited
mandate on local school districts and
property taxpayers
why would we put this financial burden
on our neighborhood public schools at a
time like this schools and educators are
doing their best to give students
stability help hope
during another challenging school year
we need support from this legislator
slater
this is not the time to drain even more
funding and resources from our schools
this is not the time to create marques
it's time to be pulling together and
doing what we can
to make this
a year of recovery for our students and
to do what we can to help them all
thrive and i thank you for your
attention
and i do have written testimony though
thank you very much are there questions
representative boom
yes
thank you mr chairman there are a lot of
laws on the books that
tell school districts what they can and
what they cannot do
so what would be the cost if all all the
school boards have to do is follow the
the cost would be in having to send a
student to any other
school or educational program in the
state and pay for the transportation and
the tuition that would be the cost but
wouldn't
follow up
but wouldn't there be no cost if the
school district just followed the law if
i believe i've already answered your
question
in the only way that
makes sense
that
transportation is not costless
tuition is not costless so we could play
a logic game if you'd like
for further further questions
represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here
i was just wondering if you might know
from your discussions with your members
in schools where they have mask mandates
currently
do schools provide for
exemptions for instance medical
exemptions
or exemptions for children who have been
vaccinated or who might have natural
immunity from having
already
survived covid
i know that schools do have
policies and they vary from district to
district but there are policies for
students with
medical
i do not know the third part of that
about students who have already had
covet so i cannot answer that one and
the one in the middle i'm trying to
recall um
immunization that varies from district
to district that is a school board
policy um that i cannot encapsulate some
do some don't
thank you are there further questions
good afternoon
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is ken eyring i live in
windham
and you know i'm looking at this
from
maybe a slightly different perspective
from some of the conversations that took
place today
i'm a former chairman of the windham
school board and i've dealt with parents
who are on both sides of many issues
and it's difficult to
make everybody happy at any given point
in time
i don't look at this as whether this is
about
i believe
that uh
you know some of the conversations was
that this is
this should be dealt with at the local
level
that this is a local control issue and
that the school boards have been elected
in order to represent the parents
and so therefore the state shouldn't get
involved
but as was
just brought up the state has made laws
and the state has made rules that have
empowered school boards to do certain
things
and if those laws and those rules are
being violated if they're not being
enacted and implemented according to the
will of the people who elected the
school boards
who in turn hired a superintendent who's
there to
represent and implement an education for
the answer
isn't always going to be
addressed at the local level these
people are elected for multi-year terms
some of them are elected on false
promises and then they're there for
multiple years
and it's difficult sometimes to get the
school boards
to listen to the parents
it's very clear last summer
that there was an uprising
across the entire country because people
were upset about crt
they were upset about mass mandates
no matter what side of the issue you're
on
it's an outrage that our federal
government turned around
and weaponized our fbi and declared
parents who are there on behalf of their
children lobbying on behalf of their
children
calling them domestic terrorists
that's where we're at right now and
that's unacceptable
everybody says when the budget time
comes up for our schools that it's all
about the kids
yet i hear people here today saying well
this is going to cost our school
districts if they have to pay for a kid
to go to another school
that might be better for them
who knows if you have kids who knows
the parents know what's best for their
children it's not a one size fit all
when i was the chairman and i served on
the school board i recognized this
i helped people
just a few
find alternative forms of education for
their kids because ultimately these are
the future leaders of our country
all of them should be in an educational
environment
that best suits
the child's needs so that they can
realize their maximum potential
this should not be a political issue
this should not be about masks whether
you should be forced to wear one or not
parents should be allowed to decide for
and if a parent decides that they don't
want their children wearing masks all
day long
recycling co2
potentially harmful yes there are
studies out there that say one thing and
the parents know what's best for their
kids and basically what this bill does
is it allows the parent to decide what's
the best educational environment for
their child
and if their child comes home every day
complaining to them and crying to them
and not learning to their potential
because they're bothered and distracted
and they're having trouble being
comfortable throughout the day
needs to be done about that
this bill
empowers parents to advocate for their
child
this bill puts puts teeth
into the words of the parents who go
before the school boards
and talk to them about their concerns
about their child wearing a mask in
school because their child is not
comfortable is not getting the education
that they need
this bill
forces the school board to listen to
those parents because if they don't
those parents now have an alternative
and the school districts will pay the
price of that and they will probably
lose half of their students
nobody should be up here advocating to
retain the authority of those school
boards who violate their oath of office
which is to
be
the servants of the people article eight
of our constitution
says that they are
the
they are the
magistrates and servants
and therefore our substitutes and shall
always be
accountable to the people
without a bill like this we have already
seen proof positive that school boards
feel like they know what's best they
don't care what the parents say and it's
time for the parents to be empowered to
do what's right for their kids
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
thank you mr chairman my name is joe
kelly i live in hooksett and i'm here to
support bill 1588
um
my mom was a teacher
and i grew up in a communist country
vietnam
so
the re-education came that
representative david loves mentioned
earlier my father spent seven years in
it in a communist prison it's a it's
called a re-education camp but there's
no education you just work physically
hard and they leave you to die when you
get sick
that's what it is so
we lived through it
and
i thought i come to america
and i have freedom here
but
we
are becoming like a communist country
like vietnam and china and north korea
and we lived it trust me
i know
other people hear that one communist and
all that they don't know jack
you i'm sorry you don't know anything
nothing if you live through what we live
through
you all wanna get rid of that ideal
that noble thought that everybody is the
same
when i was i went to school in vietnam
and i was a good student my mom only
know every teacher and she frequented my
school all the time
and you know what
she know everything that i wrote in
school too to this day she reminded me
what i wrote in my essay
that kind of involvement and yet the
school said that i felt ethic class
because i did not participate in this
extracurricular that the communist party
insisted that children a certain age you
have to participate in or else you're
going to fail your class and i was about
to be fell in that class just because
i didn't follow every kiss
i have to do the thing that the
communist party asked everybody to do so
my mom had to
allow me to participate in these
curriculum things that it's nothing to
do with education it's just pretty much
that boys and girls get in the circle
and they're all shaking hands they are
dancing and do all these stupid things
that
like everybody is the same but you know
what in my
vietnam women girl and boy you have to
be separate and we have to be proper
and yet this kind of stuff
taking away the innocence of the child
it really is ruined the parents control
and it create problems for them to have
teenagers pregnancies and all that you
know and yet i was about to be fair for
ethic for not participating in those
activities
and here i went to the windham audit in
concord for 15 days i am as an adult and
i have been bullied so many times every
time that my mask happened to follow me
off me all below my nose
people like
get it up there they get into my face
and tell me to put it up there but it's
okay for you to take it off and drink
your
water eat your apple whatever it's okay
but the minute your mask fell off just
below here they came over and sticking
my face like that
putting in my face like that so i'm as
adult i know how to defend myself
what about these poor kids
you know there's no emergency why do you
make the kids have to put all that over
their face that is abuse of children
that's a form of abuse
you know i went to so many school board
meetings
and what ken erin said
and david love said it's true
the school board treat the parents like
the enemies
it's not
funny to watch like they sit in the
cocky like you know you
we
listen to you but just
hearing but we're not listening and we
do what we want anyway
you know and if you get excited and
emotional about your kids oh you
terrorists
traders and all that that is that kind
of abusive to the parents
so we need to protect our children they
are the future
and the party of love and peace always
talking about that but how do you show
love and peace without a smile
you can't
you know many times i go to all these
hearings i don't know who's talking
because everybody have that mask on
and many times i cannot understand what
people talking even though look at their
mouth
you know
it's hard for people to understand what
we were talking about
so it's important for us to protect the
children
so if mask is a uniform of the school
then why is it not everybody don't have
to wear the same uniform
right
so if i have money in my pocket and i
want to go to this store and say mask
must wear masks to walk into this store
i'm not going to spend my money here
but the taxpayers me included already
pay for all these kids to go to this
public school
if they
are not happy with the service there
that imposing on that business because
into those school boards all they're
talking about is the students i was
shocked first time i hear that
our customers
they talking our current
customers if you the school boards
treating our students as the customers
then they must have the right to enter
that store or not to spend that money
yet the money already advanced to this
this door to this school so that money
must follow the kiss
to compensate for
that fund
so according to this bill
that funding should follow the children
and pay for all the extra because these
schools don't treat the customer right
and one more thing
the kids
they learn from the young age
something where they were just born
from even in the womb they hear you they
watch you they observe and imitate
so if they cannot imitate what they are
doing expressing love and stuff like
that how can they express themselves
we're here for the children everybody on
these boys for the children you know how
important they are
you know so it's not just about
knowledge you have to take care of their
physical their mental and their
psychological health too
so look at the suicidal rate and only
that many children have asthma a problem
how do you expect them to have that mask
on their face all day
breathing out
inhale extra oxygen and breathing out
carbon and it's blocked on your face
like that so you inhale that's mostly
carbon
you're killing the kid with the mask
unnecessarily
that that that is killing
that is dangerous endangering the child
those people that put these things in
should be prosecuted for the crime for
and
and not only that you know what
everybody walk around the only thing you
see is the eyes
we all look like we're in a muslim
country
you know nothing against the muslim
people i have muslim friends
but you know what this is america
we have freedom of expression we have
freedom of speech
but you're taking away our freedom of
expression since the child was a kid the
kids learned to be submissive and not
defending itself for what is right and
wrong and their common sense
this mask
preventing what preventing
the the
um the germs it's like you preventing a
mosquito with a linked fence that's what
it is
whatever study i don't care that's
common sense
so it's not just about the mass mandate
the money must follow the children in
the school the business the school must
treat the customer right reimburse the
money and follow the kids
and i asked for your vote
to support this bill thank you very much
thank you are there any questions
not seeing any thank you
thank you
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
the only couple of things i want to say
about this is that
i have found out recently
that our school boards unfortunately
throughout
our state are not necessarily
representing the majority of the parents
i i'm finding this out the hard way
because i'm starting to talk to parents
i haven't i
know a parent of an eight-year-old who
suffers from tourettes he has other
issues as well stuff is from tourette's
his tourette's comes out through ticks
i don't know if you folks are familiar
with what uh tick is but um
unfortunately that mask wearing creates
a lot of problems for this child he has
not been able to leak to go to his
public school
and have his iep done
because he will his parents say i will
not abuse my child by forcing him to
wear a mask
and they've said well you just got to
keep trying
that's not okay
that is not okay well just keep trying
to abuse your child
just keep trying eventually though
eventually they'll comply
students are standing up all over the
state right now they are being
charged attention
and being expelled from their schools
because they finally said enough is
enough
i want to speak a little bit to the um
to the um
sighting of the
of the the study that was cited by one
of our representatives
this is the first randomized controlled
trial this is from the study that was
quoted
trial exploring whether facial masking
prevents cobit 19
transmission at a community level it's
also noted that it's in a
i i'm sorry i'm not reading the whole
quote for time um there's a significant
risk
of of code 19
comm of in rule rule and
not well where i can't find it
um
control so this so this whole study that
was cited is with in regards to
controlled villagers
in a third world country
i just wanted to bring that to the
attention of the committee
the bottom line here is we should not be
talking about this
we should not be talking about this
discrimination is discrimination
regardless of whether
regardless regardless our school should
not discriminate our school board should
not discriminate our our businesses
should not discriminate
i'm hearing people from
organizations that say
it's going to cost a lot of money
you know what
that's still a form of discrimination
the fact that we the public are sitting
in here we become more involved we've
come here and we try to speak educatedly
on a situation we i come for the
children that i that i know personally
that i've gotten to know
through
facebook groups and some of these other
to me that is a form of bullying and it
needs to stop
thank you
thank you are there any questions
now seeing in hands thank you very much
and this closes our hearing today on
1588.
oh
i know but i'm gonna post it on facebook
three
you